I have some new tour dates I would I
would like to announce
um we are trying to come everywhere I
know people are like you got to come to
London you got to come to England
you got to come to Vietnam you got to
come Normandy there's places everybody
that people have been asking Kansas City
so we're trying to get there it's just
uh there's only so much you know time
works and and we're dealing with that
and
and everything so we're doing our best
but I would like to announce that we
have Guilford New Hampshire at the Bank
of New Hampshire Pavilion
we have Windsor Ontario on August 18th
at the Coliseum at Caesars Windsor
that's in Canada we have Niagara Niagara
Niagara Falls Niagara Niagara Falls
Ontario on August 20th at the Fallsview
Casino some of those venues are larger
uh but we will make sure that there are
screens in them so you can see
the pre-sale starts Wednesday April 12th
at 10 A.M local
with the code rat king and the General
on sale begins Friday April 14th at 10
A.M local we've also added a ninth show
in Austin Texas on June 10th at the Bass
Concert Hall and a seventh show a new
show in Phoenix Arizona
uh on April 30th at the Arizona
Financial theater those tickets are all
available get all your tickets at
theovan.com t-o-u-r
um make sure to go there for the most
accurate pricing
um and not off the secondary sites and I
know people are asking come to different
places you know and we're going to come
there uh just give us some time thank
you very much for all your support
um I did a show this past weekend and it
was in um
Fort Lauderdale and it was the largest
show I'd ever done and it was just it
was scary
um
you know it was just learning a new size
space but people had a great time and uh
just thank you guys so much I can't even
believe it
all right we have new merch I want to
let you know to check out the new root
beer hoodie
if you want the coldest root beer then
get that ice cold drip uh and the four
piece enamel pen set we got a beautiful
little pen set right there you can put a
pin on somebody put it on somebody you
love or
put on somebody who needs love or put on
yourself
if you're even if you're burying
somebody you hit him with that pan
send them with that be good to yourself
all the way to heaven
and you can check all that out at Theo
vonstore.com thank you so much for uh
wanting to support us and and wanting to
support the merch we do our best
today's guest is a stand-up comedian and
a podcaster uh you may have seen a
special live at the lodge room which
came out on YouTube last year he also
hosts his own podcast stavy's world
where he offers advice to callers he is
Greek he's a Greek man or child was a
child
and he has a new crowd work special
coming out on YouTubes this week called
four nights in New York City I had a
great time chatting with him uh today's
guest is Stavros halkias
[Music]
oh
wow
thank you
[Applause]
you know you get to some of those rural
areas or something like that and people
will bring they'll bring their sister
out there yeah it's like an event dude
yeah yeah hey you gotta meet martha like
they're like people are like it's like
going into town yeah like it's like an
hour and a half they like stock up on
like dried goods and then they go see
Theo Vaughn and they're like I guess I
gotta get kidney beans for the winter
well I'm in the well I'm in Portsmouth
and then I gotta go back to my little
[__] cabin yeah I gotta get some
cornmeal and I gotta get up I gotta get
uh Cindy Lou
a little Cindy Lou Hut Cindy Lou Who
Needs A Cindy Lou husband yeah go to the
dentist too yeah my sister you gotta
come see her here oh dude that would be
such a come up for some somebody in like
a rural ass New Hampshire if they got if
they successfully got you to like if
they basically sold their sister's [__]
for entry into your life you know what I
mean like that would be [__] that I
mean that's what marriage was truly back
in the I mean purely transactional like
oh take my daughter off my hands here's
it was the opposite you had to like give
a [__] goats to take your and
why would they do it because you're from
Greece yes so you there was a lot of
that over there was a lot of that my
grandparents are in arranged marriage
straight up my grandparents like it's
not even that [__] long ago Dude
um and it was arranged marriage is what
they have like you so arranged marriages
they say all right guess what yeah
yeah yeah this [__] guy you don't
know Darren yeah yeah yeah Stavros
actually yeah my grandfather Stavros was
married yeah the guy I'm named after
hilarious guy is he and now were they in
love or did you could you notice that
they were arranged dude there you
there's never a more ranged couple in
the history of the world like my
grandfather was so [__] she like it's
funny because you find out about him
later on and you find that about like
the guy he was outside of this weird
toxic marriage and he's like he would
help homeless people he was like really
politically active he was like you know
Greece was really the politics after
World War II were really [__] up and
he was like you know fighting fascists
and she's like he was like a cool dude
but all I knew him it was is the guy who
like wouldn't let my grandmother turn
the lights on because it because it
[__] took electricity but he would
buy he collected rare birds
and he would get like my grandmother
would go to like the [__] cheapest
like he wouldn't go out of pocket he
would have to go to like the government
doctors but he would buy his birds like
special [__] pills for their coat
make their coat shiny he would buy
vitamins and [__] this [__]
would not let her like if she ran the
[__] fan on not the air conditioning
forget they didn't have air conditioning
if the fan was going too long he'd be
like toothlessly he would be like what's
going on in there let's cut it off right
down yeah he would just Shuffle and he
would just [__] cut he wouldn't even
say [__] I'll have this owl flap its
wings for us
yeah that'll keep things cool
hell yeah my [__] cockatiels we get
we need nothing but them yeah we don't
need a ceiling faders have I have two
two cans that are here have a way boys
yeah dude wow but yeah beautiful must
that have been though back in the day if
you didn't have a ceiling fan but you
could train like six warblers to just
yeah like fly in a little circle in your
living room that would be that would be
really picaresque yeah you know you'd
feel real Whimsical and then that song
Oh Come All Ye fish
absolutely
yeah you'd have to train like parrots to
sing you yeah you don't have a fan
you're not you don't have a [__]
record player that's a good point
actually yeah the old bird uh applier
yeah
welcome to star versus all birds
appliances yeah he said yeah my
grandfather's like The Flintstones but
with birds in Greece in like 1992. it's
like fully fully had like upstairs it
was Modern this [__] had uh like
his personal fan yeah he wouldn't let
her cut the ceiling fan on but he had
like a fan before the guards like it was
literally a fan with three sharp ass
blades no no
he had a fan from before they had fronts
they hadn't invented the front of the
fan and I was like what the [__] is this
we're like being like a fat 10 year old
who's like just wants to be in air
conditioning and play [__] you know
PlayStation and I have to go hang and
like the worst part of our vacations in
Greece were like go hang out with your
grandfather and you know he's just
making like spaghetti that is so boiled
it just disintegrates on your tongue he
has no teeth
it's like a baby you know what I mean he
just shred and cheese on there and he's
like come into my come into my [__]
room him and my grandmother obviously
had separate rooms oh yeah so yeah is
that a Greek thing or not that's like a
that's uh they hated each other their
entire lives okay yeah so adulthood yeah
exactly exactly which is very I guess
now it's Progressive like I if I got
married I would want separate rooms oh
yeah yeah come hang out we'll still
probably sleep in somebody's bed
together most of the time but like I
gotta [__] have my especially we
travel all the time yeah and people now
I think there's things now like someone
might even snore at a certain octave oh
yeah it's crazy the Nuance yeah that can
lead you to sleep somewhere else from
your spouse or to want to have some
space for sure no I mean I gotta I got a
CPAP dude you do oh yeah I'm fat as [__]
dude I gotta have a CPAP and does CPAP
what does it do does it like process the
fat at night or something I wish that
would be sick if it just jiggled your
[__] no you get so fat that it's
dangerous to sleep like you get so fat
that you might just like like when
you're fat friends if they've ever like
passed out next to you and you're like
oh he snores funny it's like he's
fighting for his life oh like it's like
it's like and actually not I mean fat
people have it more than non-fat than
non-fat people but like when you hear
about like a healthy guy who's like he
ran every day and he just dropped dead
into sleep sleep apnea like it happens
to us like like non like bad snores and
[__] and that's really [__] bad for
you because it's like imagine if you
never got a good night's rest ever your
entire [__] life and it just like you
know adds up so like it'll [__] it'll
[__] it'll [__] you up and that can
happen with sleep apnea that's what so
sleep apnea is uh let's bring it up
there yeah let's get sleep apnea on the
board yeah
show me sleep apnea
what the hell that's just Steve Harvey
things that make my wife wet
leave
[Laughter]
happening is a potentially serious sleep
disorder in which breathing repeatedly
stops and starts wow so it's kind of
like that new button that they have in
cars a lot yes push to start if you're
pushed to start and you're [__]
Nissan Maxima was on the fritz yeah and
you just stopped in the highway you
might get [__] rear-ended and that's
basically suffocating in your sleep
that's a fat man yeah
he just
he just settles down like you're in a
stoplight
starting off again yeah yeah just one
big they replace one nipple with the
butt with the stay alive button yeah
just pinch it
and one time instead of she she walks
over softly right yeah and you think
she's gonna go press the button that's
how the movie ends yeah and she brings
her other hand up and there's just
flowers and she sets them on his chest
wow and she walks out of the room and
frees all the women that he's been
keeping in the basement oh so he's also
a sex criminal and goes downstairs and
tells Grandma turn on the fan turn on
the fans yeah uh oh grandpa Stavros is
dead and you hear them
everything is free suddenly yeah you
hear a strangle all the [__]
cockatiels
you hear all the birds who were his
accomplices in the sex crimes they were
he trained birds with like he would put
suction cup dildos on their heads and
they would fly rape images
let's take this scenario all the way
landing and women from just the air
just like oh damn somebody's just going
for a walk or something
yeah dude just getting raped by [__]
toucan
dude one time I was in New York and this
lady comes walking up was my first time
ever there yeah and she go did you see
that right and she kept pointing and
somebody had I guess jumped off a
building nearby because a lot of people
were gathered around God damn you know
and she's like did you see that did you
see that and so I'm looking up there and
then I said did I see what and she just
showed me her uh
vagina and she goes that guy landed in
my [__]
so is the
and that's an awesome bit awesome bit
you're not thinking about looking at a
[__] oh not at all she tricks me with
the building and then she goes that guy
landed in my [__] and showed me her now
what's going on it made me so scared
yeah and I just gotten into the city
yeah dude you're like whatever what they
told me back in Tennessee was right yeah
they're like what they told me back in
the [__] some guys like buy two
cannolis or you'll die in an hour like
it was all kind of like street street
mystery going absolutely got it scary
now I wonder what she's thinking there
in terms of first of all you don't see a
lot of female like flashers which is
kind of cool so salute to her to kind of
like bringing the glass ceiling of like
sex crimes she's breaking it by flashing
her [__] because it's hard to get a guy
not to want to look at your [__] also
you know what I mean they're up against
they're up against that most guys will
at least take a peek even if they don't
want to [__] out of curiosity I'll look
at most ladies [__] just to all right
I'll take a I'll take a look yeah you
know I mean I don't know what did she
look like was she like [__] and I
like to say Cooter honestly I do want to
say that I don't okay yeah I just don't
want these are cultural differences well
if somebody could be with their kids or
something sure sure okay yeah woman I
imagine I don't want the kid to be like
hey mom what's up right right but if
Mom's like the kids like hate me yeah
what about mother you know Cooter's cute
yeah and then volunteer like Cooter is
somebody that works at the gas station
right right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so like you know there's a lot
more mystery there oh yeah but I think
if you look at a vagina like you almost
have to look at it from the bottom I
don't feel like if you're looking
directly on it's like right it could be
any age right that's true yeah head on
you don't you're yeah you don't see the
wear and tear unless it's the the yeah I
don't feel like you wanna it's like
you need a reverse drone shot basically
it gets flying up right it just shocked
you I've never seen a woman
you know and she it was like reverse
magic like it landed in my yeah yeah
that's also really fun too to say that
he landed because what is she saying
there right that it caught her or is her
cooter so tight that maybe that's what
exploded his brain yeah you know what I
mean it's like it was in the sidewalk
that's how my I can't say Cooter I'm
sorry it feels weird
it's just for me I could say it's not
better that's probably worse right I
mean it's all fine I think I just think
of different places listening you know
sure of different environments muff
how do you feel about muff uh that some
people used to say that does say people
used to say all the time that nursing
yeah whatever
Cooter uh
uh gash is a clot [__] oh he's more
British
right you do go through it I'm sorry
that it looks like it pained you the ear
[__] I think I wonder if you have a real
distaste for everything but Cooter yeah
interesting I wonder Cuda sounds more
manageable it sounds like a animal
you're trying it's cuter for sure like
yeah maybe it could be it could be a
like a Pixar character could be named
Cooter there he is look at her
[Music]
yeah that's awesome yeah no and she has
on Heels you know yeah of course like a
squirrel yeah like a squirrel makeup
but then nowadays he comes out on stage
he's like I'm a man right right
yeah yeah yeah oh that's interesting
look Cooter named after a [__] now he's
trans or she's trans I guess a trans
squirrel named Cooter that would
honestly
that's the odds of that being in a Pixar
movie are pretty high we're gonna get a
trans squirrel in a Pixar movie the odds
of that being the next lead in like
Lethal Weapon 11.
I don't know Mel might throw his body in
front of that I mean I guess as long as
it's not a Jewish trans person he might
be down that's true do we know his
stance on
no Jews we got that's pretty well done
you think I think so I think I think
about this room I think we got metal on
juice pretty nicely I mean you didn't
even have to hear his comments just
watch Passion of the Christ it's like
this is awesome dude you learned a whole
language ancient language to be
anti-semitic because that gives you
cover when you learn the ancient
language and bring it back from the dead
he's just like no no no I'm trying to be
real if that was in English they'd be
like Jesus tone it down on the juice but
he's like but you're like whoa this is a
different tongue it's like I'm in a
different world I'm in a different place
so respect to Mel for that one yeah I
think look a lot of people I'm not gonna
say I I bought some of the merch
some of the unauthorized words yeah
like merch
um Stavros thanks for coming man yeah
dude thanks for having me uh so somehow
some audience might not know you right
and really I just think about my mom
sure because she watches the show okay
and but yeah so you started out I know
you're out of Maryland yeah and is that
weird being like a like a white person
in Maryland or in Baltimore yeah yeah I
mean I mean look I grew up Greek I mean
I'm Greek and it's Greek are y'all where
are you guys because I know it goes the
rant on the rant on the race rankings
yeah well as an ethnic white it's like
it's kind of the I kind of consider it
The Best of Both Worlds because it's
like you know we're kind of we got we
got our own Cuisine we got I speak a
different language we got a place to
vacate like the beaches are [__] sick
um weren't here for slavery huge really
that's huge yeah no my family came over
here in 82.
1382 yeah
yeah yeah
you're so right yeah I mean I'm not
saying they they never found the boats
yeah
actually the boats are not the problem
so you think Amistad was like just kind
of uh it was like fictional or it was
like a potential reimagining no I just
think it was like oh look I love Amistad
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm just
saying it's I think some things are up
for interpretation I'd be funny if you
thought slavery happened like the way it
was in Django if that's the only thing
you accepted because it was like the one
where the slaves win and you're like
yeah it was them taking advantage of us
yeah that would be a funny that would be
funny if there's like a racist guy was
like slavery didn't happen except in the
way that Quentin Tarantino said yeah and
that's how it happened and we actually
need reparations to say you know that
would be a fun Twist on it well the way
the world is now I feel like
somebody could see a movie see a
documentary and that's the I mean I
guess I don't know what they teach in
school so yeah
I feel like it's like some people you
get all your information off of one
YouTube video yeah and that is your
future
for the rest of your life you're good
dude you're all set on learning on that
topic yeah yeah it's real dangerous but
do you think you would owned a slave or
not
interesting
be here I don't know if this
conversation is going to be good yeah we
probably shouldn't move yeah like an
Abrupt cut I'm gonna say no though
before we do just for the record no and
then we can move on okay I'm okay with
talk I mean laughs
it's I mean yeah I wouldn't yeah
me neither
so we're clear and folks for those uh on
uh listening I didn't do air quotes I'm
not saying anybody else did but I
wouldn't yeah no air quotes
air quotes of the new shackles huh
I don't know about that yeah here's my
old ball in there yeah yeah dude yeah
absolutely
um no look man I believe in Freedom man
that's such an awesome take when we're
talking about slavery it's like me I'm
on the freedom side it's like that's I'm
with you too look here buddy yeah
but it was not I would say the key part
about again going to like the white mine
ethnic like uh group is if you weren't a
part of slavery yeah and you grow up in
like a uh in like a majority black city
that is a fun little like get added
being accused of racism free card where
it's like I 100 like when they're making
fun of the white trash kid whose family
like you know came over here in Ireland
300 years ago uh who couldn't afford
food who probably also couldn't afford a
slave right right right no chance yeah
and yeah no way but he was around you
know
we don't know we don't know what he was
up to we he doesn't have the papers I
know for a fact some Stavros halcus 300
years ago was on a beach like fishing or
something fishing for what though you
know black cod
black cod or [__] cod with a d okay yeah
yeah no I don't think so more maybe like
octopus
calamari a shrimp or two yeah it just
depends on what he was trying to pull
out that's true yeah no they hang up a
black cod
well what's interesting about Greek
Greek uh
Greek racism is that they don't even
like they don't have a turn like don't
get me wrong in Greece Greek people are
racist like you know there's plenty of
Greek people that are racist but there's
not even like a term for like black guy
they call like it's like it's like it's
all lumped into like Arabs like they
just like they consider black people
just like because that's that's old
school Greek racism because it's like
you know yeah the original stuff is that
the original uh yeah because Turks the
Ottoman Empire took over Greece in like
the 13 or 1400s and they really they got
our asses good for like 500 years y'all
were slaves I mean yeah pretty much not
not like in the but like in a vassal
sense where it's like these
[__] just came over we were
second-class citizens in our own country
kind of thing oh yeah but I've been to a
lot of people yugoslavians too for sure
no absolutely they the Ottomans the
Ottomans had a nice little run there and
all they got that was that piece of
furniture yeah off the strength of the
furniture they were like they what
happened is they would have real tiny
little Turks hot they would hollow out
on it was kind of they used their own
move about the Trojan Horse with they
would hollow out these Ottomans little
Turkish [__] in there pops out middle
of the night just [__] slits
everyone's throat you know they were
smart you got to get you got to give
them credit yes
just a little guy nice with the knife
though nice with the simtar yeah
that'd be crazy smallest ninja yeah dude
so tiny little real little so ninja so
yeah that's good that's a nice I would
love that's representation right there
this episode is brought to you by
betterhelp
that's right
better help
because we've all had moments where
we're not
we're not serving our best self to the
world
you know sometimes you notice you're
going through like what's going on with
me
and your answer is I don't know
and that may be where you need someone
to talk with if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time for no additional charge and
I want to remind people if you haven't
been to therapy or if if you're going to
a therapist and it's you're going but
you're not feeling like much is changing
you may want to try to switch to another
one it's totally okay it's normal
and I recommend you try until you find
what fits and what is most helpful
discover your potential with better help
visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o today to get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com
Theo have you had a family member that's
been heard in an auto accident or been
autoed out bang bang and that's the next
thing you know you're jacked up you're
jacked out
well Morgan and Morgan is America's
largest injury Law Firm they have over
100 offices Nationwide and more than 800
lawyers
that's right with over 15 billion
dollars recovered for clients Morgan and
Morgan has a proven track record of
fighting to get you full and fair
compensation
if you feel like something was unfair
and then sometimes you need help in
those instances and they can help
submitting a claim to Morgan and Morgan
is easy it's more like using an app than
hiring a lawyer with Morgan and Morgan
you can submit a claim without ever
having to leave your couch in eight
clicks or less you can submit a claim to
Morgan and Morgan
if you're ever injured you can check out
their fee is free unless they win for
more information go to forthepeople.com
this past weekend or dial pound law
that's pound 529 from your cell phone
that's for the people.com slash this
past weekend or pound 529 pound law from
your cell this is a paid advertisement
but one thing I'll say about the Ottoman
Empire that's cool because they were
Muslim and Greeks were we were Orthodox
Christian they gave they wouldn't all
the pork you know they think it's
unclean and [__] you guys got it they
gave it to us that's how Gyros came
about that's how a Euro happened so if
it wasn't for
400 years of semi slavery in Greece we
wouldn't have a Euro and it's like
from where I'm standing that's that's an
easy trade I didn't have to be
semi-enslaved by [__] you know Sultan
I'm just eating the [__] sandwich
that came out of it so I'm pretty
[__] pumped personally about it
oh God yeah damn oh yeah so you are
you've had a great couple last couple of
years I mean you've had a yeah you know
no it's been a sick it's been crazy was
it was it what was it like coming up in
uh in Baltimore because I remember I
went over there to um mcgoobies oh Helly
the Goobs and I got offered a threesome
I forgot about that oh in Baltimore yeah
uh there was a woman and a man it was a
black female and a white male right like
I'm a dispatcher or something
yeah that's where the Baltimore flares
up in me it's like yeah absolutely that
is a very Baltimore thing
um and they kept kind of eat they kept
kind of circle like they were hanging
out a little too long yes lingering
after the show and they have that bar
built yet no because now they have a bar
attached to it that's a good place for
like a crowd to linger to try and [__]
you would be the bird but you're saying
you're just in the lobby of magoobies
yeah I'm just lobbying around out there
I'm just like a I guess a lobbyist or
whatever
yeah I'm just out there and they were
kind of hanging around and they were
like hey we just want to let you know
you know we live here nice if you'd like
to come back and spend some time with my
wife you know oh so it wasn't even a
threesome it was like a [__] situation
he wanted you to [__] his wife in front
of him
maybe see I didn't know I guess I didn't
see like all there wasn't like a fan
foot or anything you know so I didn't
see all of the details yeah absolutely I
was like damn dude I don't you know
spend some time with my wife sounds like
I want you to [__] my wife it doesn't
sound like hey you [__] my wife while
she sucks my dick it sounds like I want
I'm gonna be in a little chair and I'm
gonna be watching you [__] my black wife
yeah that's what it sounds like to me
like he's just gonna sit on an ottoman
that would be good too because that
further that further like you know puts
him in a position of like uh not not my
dumb brain isn't working I was gonna say
a position of not power right which
shows you how [__] dumb I am which is
there is a word I'm looking for and I'm
not gonna get it I'm gonna filibuster
until maybe I think of it like a
tertiary position no
no like uh it doesn't matter we're gonna
like an inferiority inferior position
even more inferior position right yeah
yeah because when you're lower you're
more yeah you're at least more of a
Supporting Cast or absolutely yeah and
you would think if you're on a bed he's
on an ottoman he might be looking
directly into his wife's Cooter as your
[__] is going in and out that was that
oh well you gotta I can't say [__] yeah
you can it's just man
[Laughter]
you you jump off a building and crack
open
like a Kinder Egg yeah and I'm full of
pornography oh it's just a bunch it's
like a uh it's like a couple of cast
members from uh black yeah or
bangbus.com
yeah they come out some teen was [__]
inside of inside of a small bus inside
of my stomach that's what's going on
somebody wearing olives is wrist let's
just come out completely naked
damn dude so but I'm just saying if you
were a cook a lower position where you
could peer directly into the action
would be even more humiliating in my
opinion you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah that's a shame you didn't take them
off have you ever been in a in a in a
three-way we had a woman or man somebody
emailed us one time and tried to give me
money to fly out there to um San
Francisco to make love to their wife wow
interesting but only those couple times
let me think
I'm sure you've got plenty of you and
two girls in the Heyday when you're real
[__] you know when you're getting [__]
up all the time oh I think there was one
time I remember I was in I think
Missouri or something right
and they had this one lady and she was
just a real she was vibey she was just a
damn drum beat I love that dude yeah a
lot of silk what are we talking like uh
when you say vibe that in my head I'm
thinking belly dancer I'm thinking like
you know what I mean
yeah I love how in Greeks with Greek
stuff even the dancer still has a belly
[Laughter]
nothing wrong with God's tit dude I bet
now this would be interesting if women
got a nipple installed on that belly
instead of that whatever the hole is the
bunch is so outdated let's get that out
of there yeah
but not even a third one like a [__]
awesome it's third right but it's the
biggest best one oh oh yeah it's a yeah
yeah it's like um
wow that's genius honestly dude that's
you're a [__] genius for that one
because that's that's like that's like a
[__] taking your weakness and turning
it into your greatest strength in a
heartbeat yeah
I got a giant stomach
here's the best part yeah in a dude's
brain yeah it would feel like awesome
absolutely just this doing this
one giant titty so in your you close
your eyes it's like you're sucking like
a giantess tits like yeah like uh the
guy from Jack and the Beanstalk the guy
at the top Charlie the giant right I
believe Charlie was the guy climbing oh
Charlie was the guy no it wasn't a Jack
or the one-eyed thing oh yeah
no Jack died I think his brother started
doing it oh [__] okay it's like a
Gallagher too situation
he just takes Charlie just takes [__]
Jack's whole [__] and starts climbing up
beanstalks
he's a NEPA baby
but yeah I remember this one lady from
Missouri so she had
she was real vibey she just kind of was
like
um she was cute sure when we say Vibes
so we're talking like hippie vibey
Crystal's vibey no uh just pretty clean
I guess clean okay a woman you want to
[__] is what you mean I mean a woman who
it's like hey wow uh look at this clean
lady okay
if I would describe his body but you
know again a culture somebody you could
lay next to and not feel like oh man I'm
gonna get like you know I'm gonna get
stains on my shirt or whatever like you
know just a
a tidy lady yeah I would say what you're
describing is like the bare minimum for
wanting to have sex with someone yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that's why Ivy all right no I got yeah
so anyway she invites me over
and she had a friend with her right and
the friend had this very like um
she looked like one of those weight
lifters from like the 1906 or something
with the barbell that had the stuff
like 12 pounds of 7 000. of course so
she had like a singlet on like a one a
little curly mustache you know like it's
just like a yeah yeah it's like a
leotard or whatever like uh the Big Show
would wear yes yes she had that man and
she was jacked she's like I'm down to
make love or you know try to try to make
love if you want to do it but my friend
is gonna do it also wow now the strong
girl is her friend yeah so the VA now
what would you say is the strong girl is
she vibey as well the strong girl is
more strong okay
okay and so you wouldn't you didn't [__]
them I don't remember honestly what
happened I don't even remember that's
crazy you do remember I think it blocked
out
you're getting [__] deadlifted by the
strong girl I mean she grabbed you by
the penis and just
clean and clean and jerk you and then
sucked you off like she's [__]
sucking your dick like this overhead
press oh
uh the other girl's just watching Martin
she's not even involved
[__] that's crazy yeah well I hooked up
with a strong girl I don't want to do my
ACT it's in it's a I do a joke in my uh
in the special about the tape in May but
I did hook up the strong girl and I
really did like it she was it was
[__] sick yeah she had giant like
muscly ass thighs and it was like a
battle dude it was like I was in there
and like you know you're eating [__]
it's like you're the strongest one in
the equation it's like you have total
control of the person's body while
you're going down on them
with her it was not I was nodding like
it was like oh it was like when it's
like a storm on a ship yeah you're just
like Hold On batting down the hatches
it was like oh I was like truly like
Suffolk like she was squeezing like
sometimes a girl will squeeze her thighs
when you're eating her [__] this girl
was doing that and I was like having
trouble breathing really because she was
that strong yeah but you also have
I mean that's like a c it's not as
that's like a c [__] yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah cracking that's like
putting on the seat first
yes yes yes but dang so do you have
trouble being down there yeah are you
like one of those like
fillet in like
pugs or whatever they can't breathe you
know no no no it's usually not a problem
the CPAP doesn't kick it no no I'm not
I'm not I'm not snoring into the [__] I
don't wear that like that little dog a
pug yes absolutely and like why isn't he
soaking here yeah I'm like it looks like
two sneezes they're beating the [__] out
of him from the inside yeah I don't know
you better hope his [__] have
allergies he's done
dander will kill your dog
no no no breathing problems luckily
while I'm awake and eating [__] think
praise praise God for that one
um so you came out of Baltimore
yeah it is it's funny because you have a
real you sort of have like real people
on the show it's so funny yeah it
juxtaposition between like you know
famous singers episodes then like you
ask one question we're talking about
eating strong [__] for like 45 minutes
and it's like you know it's just such a
funny I love it dude yeah the show has
range yeah we try to
we try to well a lot of stuff it's like
I want to learn about in the most free
time I have to sit and talk with
somebody is in here no I get that dude I
fully get that you know so it becomes
kind of nice sometimes when you can talk
to somebody and learn about something
new I wish that my memory worked a
little bit better sometimes but yeah
dude I don't remember [__] that I said
or Taken like I love I've started
reading books just because I can't go to
sleep and my brain is so dumb that if I
read it'll be like it'll just shut off
instead of having to read you know what
I mean like so but I enjoy like I legit
have some kind of learning disability
and like and so that's just a trick for
like I put my phone in the other room
and I read and truly my brain will shut
off and I remember like like I'll tell
my friends like dude this book was
[__] sick the call you know I just
read this book called the cold 6000 and
I'm like and they're like oh awesome
what's it about I was like
um [__]
there's it's like Cuba or like like
Kennedy's like I don't know [__] but in
the moment I love it like I I retain
readings like minimally I could not tell
you any I'm reading a book about like
what the [__] am I ready now altered
carbon it's pretty good it's like a
detective like [__] sci-fi oh yeah is
that by Michael uh oh bro Michael oh oh
okay yeah
yeah
it's kind of a bus it's crazy how every
tall black guy just expected to go play
basketball yeah that's gonna be there
should be like a rescue for that like
right like there should be a group that
goes into the NBA and just get ghosts
and a really good job long sweaters
get in the middle of the night like
you're not you don't know you you don't
want to be in here be a Drama teacher
yeah I'm a giant you want to work at the
airport yeah you want to be a Veterinary
that would be sick
in his sleep just posting people up yeah
yeah it is funny though because that's
the only time where if you are over
seven feet you can be completely you can
have no coordination whatsoever hate
Sports hate basketball they will just
force you to play some level of pro
sports yeah like like that does have to
be annoying for the guy who really is a
[__] in his heart and soul really is
a veterinarian he really wants to be
spaying cats but he's got a [__] you
know try and guard Giannis you know like
he's like I just want to [__] snip a
Pug's nuts off right
[__] CPAP machine
don't buy a Joel embiid right now that's
got to be at least one but you know and
they don't even I mean they make money
but they don't even if you're like a
shitty end of the bench big
they make like a you know you make a
million bucks two million I don't know
what the what the NBA veteran minimum is
right now yeah but if it's like if
they're making the minimum and then you
know half that shit's gone for taxes and
10 aging and [__] it's like they're
really not that rich and it seems like a
horrible life to be you're traveling all
the time like if you're not super
[__] rich and it's not cool if you're
just at the end of a bench and you hate
it and you'd rather be doing some other
[__] yeah kind of a [__] you know
worst case scenario yeah yeah it's got
to kind of be tough I think especially
you get there and you're like yeah do I
even want to be here but then at the
same time you've done enough work to be
in but then I wonder how many guys lose
their desire because they don't even get
to play in the games yeah probably a lot
you know that's
imagine like being in a band there's a
band right yeah yeah there's def
leppards or whatever yeah and then they
have three four backup leopards
yeah they can hear right they're right
now I'm just sitting there on the side
yeah you know the first couple of shows
are like we're gonna get in the game
they're priming their instruments and
stuff you know or you go in you get to
play one chord and they're like all
right come out the other leopards are
back in yeah with three minutes left in
a song they'll put you in it's like a
long song while the guys they want to
get a head start on getting their dick
sucked by the groupies yeah so they like
just call in the backup leopards that
would be sick but then you never get
into by the after after that 30th show
where you still are you still sitting
over there pretending are you doing you
know you and you and the other guy next
year just you know trying to do how many
zins you can do in your mouth at once
you know playing [__] Zen daddy with
your buddy before you both leave your
wife for each other you know
that sounds beautiful actually that
sounds like a love story yeah in in the
darkness of being backup bass players or
whatever we've concocted here they found
gay love two men nine cents
so that's actually beautiful I'm
actually I've turned around on the whole
thing now because I think that's awesome
maybe there's giant 7-2 guys or
discovering they're gay
with other guys on the bench
that's a lot of gay sex by the way two
seven Footers [__] each other in the
ass bro what are you talking about
just go like this dude
I'm sorry man you know what can I say
it's again cultural differences is a
real you know I came in in the tracksuit
Baltimore this is just kind of how we go
about stuff
we just kind of talk about people
[__] each other in the ass pretty
openly I think so it's more more vulgar
East Coast that's true East Coast poor
City yeah if you come from like a shitty
town you know you're talking about that
kind of [__] yeah right
everyone's pretty outwardly horny
there's no like there's no like that
that veneer of like you know decorum
that you got in the south
where it's like you kind of hide your
desires
yeah but it's just hidden though it's
just hidden behind like something it's
barely hitting like behind a picture of
lemonade yeah you can see it you can see
yeah yeah yeah like oh right behind here
you have some pedophils yeah
oh they got that here
[Laughter]
um how are we doing on audio and stuff
in there
okay oh yeah baby
um I also want to say before we go to
the next question that we then somehow
end up talking about two seven four guys
[__] each other in the end we we got
strong we got strong girls [__]
strong girls and then uh gay seven
Footers real fast I have a uh I'm on
tour and I got a crowd work special
coming out tomorrow the day after this
comes out so congratulations yeah just a
little something yeah a little something
you know on the YouTube for free for the
people out there so go to YouTube I've
been trying to put all my [__] on
YouTube I mean that shit's helped my
career the most it's just throwing [__]
on YouTube unbelievably right it's crazy
yeah and so you're from clubs to
theaters so it did so for so that's like
there's like a little bonuses I don't
even consider this like a special it's
like a half hour crowd work special I
did like some shows to warm up for this
tour the fat Rascal tour uh and I just
took I did four shows in New York and I
just took the best like moments and we
put it together so free special go watch
that and I also have my other special my
original special for free on YouTube
when I'm working on the next the actual
crowd the actual material one and this
and that first one really would you say
that that had a big step in pushing you
to a different space Oh yeah for sure I
mean that I was already just like doing
clips and [__] which I thought like I
never thought people would want to see
35 second or 45 second crowd work Clips
like I thought that was you know I was
like well that's not what stand-up is
that's not what you want to do but I was
like I'm putting out a YouTube special
you know at the end of this year so in
like February of like the year that I
put the special out I was like well I
have like because I was recording every
show I did to work on the special I
would watch them back I was like I gotta
like try and make this good because it's
like you know people give me as like a
podcast they didn't know it was a
comedian so I was working hard on that
[__]
and then I had all these like little
crowd work moments and I was like well
these are we'll just throw them away if
we don't put them up yeah these are
viable yeah we might as well just throw
them up there because my YouTube channel
had like 20 000 subscribers and I was
like throw them up there see what
happens and like that [__] helped grow
the channel crazy and then because I
think YouTube was just trying to steal
tick tock's whole [__] like and so when
they whenever they do that they push all
that new stuff the algorithm just any
kind of like little clip like anything
pushes it and uh and yeah dude and then
people started like subscribing the
channel and then once you had a little
bass and then I put the special out
there it was like [__] it was crazy I
couldn't even like truly I still can't
believe like I did my first I did a
bunch of theater shows in Chicago and it
you step out and you're like who the
[__] are these people how the [__] how
the [__] are that 5 000 people know who
I am and want to see me in Chicago they
want to hear my stories about almost
suffocating eating [__] from a
bodybuilder like 5 000 people in a city
I've been to three times last time I was
here I did I did uh last time I was in
Chicago I played uh the Lincoln Lodge
great fun room it's a 90 seater you know
what I mean it's like one year later
it's like the Vic you know so it's like
it it blows my [__] mind and you know
shout out to the shout out to the
algorithm baby I'm sucking on the
algorithm nicely the third I look at the
algorithm yes
I'm just I'm I'm [__] breastfeeding
on the nipple stomach right now
um we do yeah I mean it's I remember
when you're when your special came out
um well I remember I remember I met
somebody that was on uh
you know what I'm talking about c-u-m-t
okay yeah you I think we met way back in
the day was it serious it's serious yeah
did you have no did you have children no
hair dude we were yeah dude like oh my
God seven years ago we did a serious raw
dog podcast and it's like none of us I
mean like you were doing better but not
like this and I was nowhere like we were
just like God you were like a guy
working clubs and I was a guy working
like Thursdays and Sundays oh my god
dude I have looked up because I've
looked you didn't know that was me no
you didn't know the bald guy you made it
serious six years ago it was me
and I've been looking for him
I know you're not I can see it in your
eyes look at calm down and I'm like I
swear to God this dude was from Compton
wow yeah dude we met so long ago and
that was a fun that was a fun podcast
that we didn't know each other at all we
were just kind of shooting his show was
it
I don't know it was like uh or that guy
Aaron no dude it was like it was like
the guy like like such a low level
serious show it was like the producers
son or something yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was hilarious and it wasn't even like a
studio it was like in an office they put
four mics in remember yeah I was like
you know what the [__] you know I
remember yeah somebody yelled the n-word
right when I walked in there sorry about
that
I was like all right I'll stay yeah
sorry Sherrod made me really mad
how long was Sherrod small
the only black dude in that Circle that
rotation dude Opie had charad back to
back that's cool bro yeah man R.I.P yeah
let's spread let's start that Sharon's
been dead for years
yeah good guy though good guy what are
you gonna do dude that's the best thing
about like a lot of black guys you can
just go up like no remember little Steve
and bro in it but like yeah I remember
little Steve he was like he passed away
bro and he'd be like no instantly they
won't ask a follow-up and I'll be like
damn
they got it's always they got little
Steve they got a little Steve dude yeah
like who are they yeah you know I love
the Starbursts yeah
it was like a blush for sure yeah you
know
center cut bacon you know that's what
got little Steve which by the way is
also Steve I believe Stephen Van Zant's
name in the E Street Band
little Steven yeah right little Stephen
VanZant yeah God Silvio
um but yeah dude that's hilarious yeah
and so you guys don't do that anymore
you guys still no she stopped we stopped
the show like uh last year I would dude
I was [__] because you love bro I
remember you telling me how freaking
good it was it was fun dude it was a fun
it was a fun I remember that now yeah we
we had just started and the show was I
looked at the lettering it had semen
coming off like yeah it was pure come uh
but that's the show you do when you're
like you know in your mid-20s with your
boys and it was like yeah when you got
extra calm yeah when you got come to
spare and now I'm I need every I need I
need uh you know I'm drinking extra
fluids when I know I'm Gonna Make Love I
want to make sure I'm fully I'm getting
an IV straight to my balls just to make
sure plenty of coming there
but yeah dude the show was [__] fun
for a while and then you know I was like
damn am I going to be the calm Town guy
when I'm 40. oh you know it's like it's
like you can't when you're when the
person yeah yeah
and if most people in my life were like
oh yeah you will be come on dude stop
having stop getting greedy you fi you
found the gimmick stick with it you'll
have to make [__] dick you know being
gay with your friends jokes until you
die which I still do something right
none of that will ever end it shouldn't
yeah no no no but you know so then it
was just like uh
you know I was like an evolution kind of
yeah I just want to do my own thing
because it's like I like you know
because you do your own show it's nice
to just be the only person who has to
schedule anything you just do it on your
own time oh yeah [__] you know yeah I
mean I did another show too for a while
I did King in the sting and it was fun
but I started to miss I didn't have
enough energy really to focus on like
what my own world was yeah yeah and what
made me feel comfortable and the
scheduling it becomes a lot people think
we're only working a couple hours a week
it's a lot it's there's a lot more to it
that you don't see exactly not
complaining but that's what it is yeah
and that was basically it where I was
like I also just really wanted to focus
on stand-up
and I had this I had the special just
come out and I was like you know I
thought I was gonna just like kind of
take a little break special was out
retool do all this [__] and then I
stopped doing come town and then my ship
blew up and I was like wait I can't the
break is never happening yeah I've just
been on the road for two years since
like I still I have to take like after
that's why I'm filming this special it's
a little early but I was like I need the
summer off because I'm gonna [__] die
and like if yeah as long you will die so
uh so yeah
um and I just kind of like really went
crazy on stand up and then just after a
while I was like I guess I should just
do a podcast I'm good at it I did so I
just started stoppy's world and I just
do it in my own you know I do it in my
own uh uh extra bedroom there it is we
just had bird on yep Rachel Feinstein
Mark Normand I've had some good some
good blokes on there
Monroe Martin yeah awesome yeah Monroe
is oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's something about him he's one of
the people you get around him and you
just kind of feel good great hang great
hang great stories about his you know
deadbeat father on the podcast oh yeah
is that Ryan sickler no yes it is yeah
he just had a new special come out yep
just put him on there what's his special
that just came out uh Lefty's son yeah
Lefty son also from Baltimore that's my
dude yeah yeah we come he came on he
just did the podcast and we just talked
I was we just were like naming
neighborhoods in Baltimore for like you
know 40 minutes yeah it's like if you
know it's like you know he really did
live in every white trash part of
Baltimore oh dude he's uh there's every
time I'm around Ryan here there's a part
of him it's like that reminds me of a
part of me that just never left the
neighborhood yeah dude like you could
have dude you could have uh you know you
could have a big old spatula and you'll
never [__] pry that part out of the
neighborhood you can't leave absolutely
part of me is still over there
absolutely cooking wieners over like a
like somebody's made like a fire where
they're burning like stuff that's
flammable that's bad yeah yeah and then
I'm over there the penny Savers in there
yeah
so all that toxic gas just going
straight into the flavor brother
straight into that meat making that
weenie extra [__] tasty have you
discovered subscriptions that you've
forgotten about
maybe you're getting these you keep
somebody keeps saying sending you dang
soap suds you get another box of soap
suds and the cats in them and he's all
soaked out he's got you know soap in his
cat eyes
and he's catting around but he can
barely do it because he's soaked out
well rocket money they'll help
over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions they've forgotten about
and chances are you're one of them like
that stars app just to watch one show or
the HBO trial or this or that
all of it you forget rocket money will
quickly and easily find your
subscriptions for you and for any that
you don't want to pay for anymore just
hit cancel
and they'll cancel it for you it's that
easy over three million people have used
rocket money saving the average person
up to 720 a year stop throwing away your
money cancel unwanted subscriptions and
manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com Theo that's
rocketmoney.com Theo rocketmoney.com
Theo you know I am a big fan of Raising
Canes their first location was in
Louisiana and now they're everywhere
and they got them chicken fingers baby
God
boy when I see him my tongue sees them
that's how they are
and they got them crinkle cut fries man
looked like somebody just gave them
babies just a beautiful little haircut
right when they come out that fryer they
got that buttery Texas toast
just want to lasso that
and they do it All Canes you know I love
the Caniac combo that's my go-to over
there
and I gotta let you know that it's so
easy to order on their mobile app or
online at raising canes.com you can
check it out and treat your taste buds
like it's the like it's their dang
wedding day
satisfy your canes fixed fast ordering
through their app or online at raising
canes.com or stop by your local
restaurant if you have an upcoming
summer trip planned if you're planning
to go somewhere
and the place you're going maybe they
it's a um it's a country
it's a new country have you been there
no
what are you gonna say when you get
there huh you don't know but Babel does
Babel is the largest language learning
app
that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions thanks to Babel's
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lessons
there's still time to learn a new
language before you get there
with Babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you can start
having real life conversations in as
little as three weeks
they have all types of languages over
there you can learn French Italian
German
plus Babel's speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and accent
yup right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to babble.com
Theo that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-.com
Theo for up to 55 off your subscription
Babble language for life
um it's amazing to see people doing them
onto YouTube and stuff these days one
thing that I think is also easier it's
easier to find stuff on YouTube yeah for
sure I think it's really easier like
Netflix is just trickier to find it
doesn't it's not the same YouTube Feels
I also think it's a generational thing
dude like young people the way we grew
up like just throw the TV on they're
watching YouTube or they're watching
like twitch [__] we don't even think of
like twitch right so that's just the way
where it's like people have YouTube is
the default thing is like when you just
want to throw some [__] on and I've even
started like going to that going to that
a little bit where it's like I'll watch
like these [__] long like you know
history [__] about like I literally
watched a Greek Independence Day I
watched an hour and 15 minute video
about the Greek and the war for
independence and it's just like this guy
kings and Generals that guy [__]
rules it's just some guy with a British
accent with like shitty cartoons they're
not even fully animated it's like you
know picture and he's just describing
war that happened I'll watch more
Eclipse dude I love watching full
episodes of uh paternity Mori where
they're talking about you know a lot
just when the lie detector tests come
out it's [__] there's just so so much
good [__] on YouTube where you're like
yeah I'm good I'll watch this I'll watch
full episode you know bootleg episodes
of [__] it's awesome
yet or so yeah I love how here's what
you can get to anything immediately from
anything else anything that pops in your
imagination you can get something about
it immediately yeah
um it's the best algorithm too like it's
the one where you're like oh I am
interested in this right whereas like
other [__] like you know you'll watch
like you know [__] like on Instagram
or whatever their for you page like
because you know this is your semi there
right when you watch them on YouTube and
they're like hmm I'm in the next thing
they suggest is like yeah I'm in there
although I will give Tick Tock some
credit there I had to get off because
their algorithm was so good that it was
like it was truly for me it was
literally like sandwiches and girls with
huge tits and it's like man you figured
me out man you know what I mean it's
like but and then it started getting
worse because it actually got deeper
into like then it started showing you
like a hot woman with like a baby and it
was almost like this like you're 34 you
should have this should be your life
like they really were getting into your
psyche and then it went from like they
get you with like the bass [__] of like
food and sexy girls oh yeah and then
it's like becomes like a wholesome
content where it's like oh don't you
want a family and then it's like now
you're following these babies and you're
watching these like celebrity babies
grow up instead of your own family yeah
it's like fights [__] up dude
yeah
I was super invested in like a Korean
family like like they had like a food
blog where they would like feed their
one-year-old like you know dumplings and
he'd be like
and I'd be like hell yeah dude that's
awesome I'm just like happy just purely
and then I'm like this is so [__] up
like they're they found a way to like
get into even your biological urges of
like having a family they've hacked us
they've fully hacked us bro well that's
one of the issues these days man I feel
like people are we are fully hacked man
yeah we are fully hacked and if you look
at uh like there's that new chat GPT or
whatever that came out yeah yeah yeah
and I've gotten like some people send me
stuff like hey man look at this comedy
set of yours we that we had chat GPT do
right yeah yeah and I'm like this is
track like this sucks it just sounds
like you put anybody if you say like
from Louisiana or from a Southern state
it just sounded it felt really cheap to
me yeah so I wonder how like Advanced
they can get that you know yeah I mean
it's true they I do think and maybe it's
just us thinking like oh come on you
can't the one thing you can't figure out
is comedy but what they do with all the
AI the the art stuff is they just steal
from artists right so like uh that's a
good point so they will what they'll do
is just steal jokes and like just put it
in another like I even saw like uh Will
Sasso did something really funny he has
like a he has like an AI like dudesius
podcast is run by an AI and he did like
a Tom Brady Tom Brady because you know
Tom Brady just sent me that yeah he said
he said to me too and I looked at it and
I was like this is gonna be [__]
stupid and it was like it was like they
didn't have the pausing of stand-up
comedy right but they were real jokes
right and but then you hear that and
you're like I've I've heard these before
right and it's like clearly what the AI
did was steal maybe even shitty
comedians probably what they did was go
to YouTube or wherever and stole like
[__] Open Mic level Comics or Like
mid-tier Comics or like you know
starting out comics and just stole the
Rhythm and [__] of jokes and put it in
there some of the jokes were
legitimately funny they might have
stolen stuff from you know anybody
so I think that's what that's what
that's why the [__] is so unethical it's
like not only is it are they you know
learning [__] that's scary that
computers can do but they're just
stealing art from people they're just
stealing techniques from people and it's
like an amalgam of [__] from people that
from real people that worked very hard
to do it right but they're gonna be
probably jokes that are very like
pattern based I feel like she can have
like a lot of writers like joke writer
style sure I think you a performer
may be able to
yeah then even rise up like still have
some uniquity to them I'm not sure but
you're gonna have to have a powerful
level of uniquity if somebody yeah I
love uniquity but if somebody yeah and
that's not a racial slur either it's not
a racial slur it's not a girl that works
at the post office it's neither of those
things
iniquity the girl that tried to [__] you
at my goobies
iniquity and her husband Kyle
dude actually now that you say you're
right like there's something to
Performance but it's even funny because
it's like well if we're talking about a
robot that learns jokes it's like is
Mark Norman the first comedy AI like
it's Mark the first like that literally
like I feel like that's what that
[__] is he's so good he just
feed a joke in and it's like Bam Bam
everything is just like he's incredible
yeah yeah being around he's a guy that I
missed not being able to be around a lot
of times yeah yeah just so awesome about
him yeah yeah great hang but yeah I just
I'm wondering like like they just said
this how influential this stuff is
getting will you bring that up
um they had a guy who killed
who took his own life he was having a
relationship
with a chat GPT bot I think and he was
texting and the woman at some point was
like look it's
you're not I'm not real you're not doing
life right or something you gotta check
out man ends his life after an AI
chatbot encouraged him to sacrifice
himself
to stop climate change
[Laughter]
not next the [__] is that
now here's the crazy part
a belt let's zoom in a little please
yeah a Belgian man reportedly ended his
life following a six week long
conversation about the climate crisis
with an artificial intelligence chat
that's awesome
so what do they mean by according to his
widow oh yeah he had a wife according to
his widow Pierre not the Man's real name
became extremely eco-anxious when he
found refuge in Eliza in AI chatbot on
an app called chai shy now here's what's
interesting now here's what I think this
is here's what I think is happening hit
me with it
I believe that most of everything you
see in the world today is advertising
right it's a lot of advertising and then
it's they bait you for stuff that's
going to come out later I bet this was
this is a fake article yeah okay well
you're sorry your own use dot next which
sounds real
next sounds real to me it does
but if it were like dot last or whatever
yeah
oh you're out okay but yeah you got your
news.next dude and it sounds like they I
feel like are dialed in but here's what
I don't here's what's gonna happen yeah
they're gonna say like uh they're gonna
write us this they're going to see how
much publicity an article gets then
they're gonna someone in Hollywood right
because the media and Hollywood they're
all in simpatico of course is going to
write a script about it and then they're
gonna make it like it's a uh based on
real life story and then it becomes so
they test articles on the public to see
what gains enough traction okay and then
after that they'll write a script and
then a year from now it comes out a
movie don't you remember yeah
um remember when you when we all start
our day with
euronews.next don't you remember that
day you woke up had your coffee logged
on the euronews.next and saw the story
about Pierre and the chai and Eliza I
bought yeah
why yes I do
but I will I mean isn't that the movie
her without the like isn't that without
the like they're trying to re yeah it's
something they're just trying to put a
span on her so I'm sure it'll be a
copyright issue on it yeah yeah you know
so now we have a copyright issue on fake
wow on on on something that's completely
fake we don't even know the Nay I didn't
make that story up I wouldn't be shocked
to keep us off the trail that'd be the
first story an AI would make up how cool
they are they got some [__] French
loser to kill himself
I am going to run the oven and put my
head inside of it
I cannot do it anymore
I mean what does his wife have to if
this is real imagine being this guy's
wife and being like damn dude you didn't
even like cheat on me yeah you mean the
Mona Lisa yeah he's a moaning even
louder because it's so [__] hot
please give me [__] Mr Robot I will get
I will to kill myself if I get a little
robot [__]
through blue balls
dude how many
how soon until we're begging robots for
cooter
soon oh and you know they got I mean
dude they're gonna they're not gonna
have good you think they might bro have
you seen those like Chinese dick sucking
machines dude if I started two iuds in
it it was a nightmare that's too many
iuds I know but can you imagine it's
Gotta feel hella iudish if you're a uh I
don't think Shabbat I don't think so you
don't think I think they will figure out
a way to warm it up real Lube like truly
if you pull up
style to set you like your uh
yeah yeah let's get this robot [__] a
little warmer
you'll be able to like adjust tightness
temperature dude I'm telling you they're
gonna figure out figure it out it's
gonna feel so sad though yeah for sure
because here's the saddest part
you have to take it back and set it
somewhere you have to close its eyes
with your no no this is like we're
talking about here's a picture of a man
with it right here no I'm not interested
in that but remember that you ever see
the movie ex machina
mm-hmm it's good but basically the
robots are like people
and like when they get to that level of
robot where you can like walk around a
little bit and it's not a it's a
semi-sentient being that's trained to
like give top no that would be awesome
hey bro you just you just said it right
walk around a little bit so basically
it's gonna be like you're chasing
somebody that's like injured right
yeah it's like one of those dogs those
dog robots yeah somebody like it takes
one I don't know hold on how about this
the Boston Dynamics robots they're doing
flips and [__] what if they use that
technology to suck dick you're not gonna
go for that I don't know dude you're not
going to afford a Boston Dynamics hooker
dude dude but not yet but when not on
The Cutting Edge but when it gets to
like mass production it's gonna be a
bootleg Dyson
you can already pretty much [__]
Dyson yeah but it'll have two speeds Man
Regular and
[Laughter]
if they teach that thing to jack you off
you're you're now we're calling the
police first of all
second of all yeah the only thing this
thing is look at that thing it's jumping
and [__] dude this is how they'll
advertise this thing once it comes out
to they'll put one into a uh
God damn that sucks I hate that this
exists the biggest uh or that say uh uh
America's Got Talent oh yeah and it'll
win it will win and people like now what
because it sucks Howard Stern's dick
because it'll win it'll do gymnastics
and then it'll also suck you off Howie
Mandel is going to be going crazy yeah
look at these guys dude oh wow is that
real or huh no
no way that's [__] real dude that's
not [__] CGI
I hate that that [__] and also look
at their white too black people are
gonna be pissed about that
I'm like oh the first ones was white huh
I think though I think yeah I mean they
do yeah you got to put some color on
these yeah you guys dude you do just go
like a mob or something at least make it
like it could be anybody something Regal
or taupe taupe would be good too I hate
these these [__] suck actually unless
that's they have to appeal they have to
make them sex robots because otherwise
we're gonna be talking about like how
these are you know these will be cops
like they'll be patrolling they'll be
like well to think about our civil
liberties being lost but if they teach
if they release them as sex robots first
get everybody get everybody like horny
on them we'll all of a sudden not care
as much that like these will be doing
like you know surveillance with no
warrant on like you know communities I'm
like you know like that's what these are
going to be used for you these are going
to be police things for sure dude but
security for sure bro if you telling me
though those little dog ones [__] that
dude but one of these rolls through the
hood bro you telling me it rolls through
the trenches brother ain't gonna have
[__] a couple Brothers out there
popping they should you see what they do
the ice cream truck already I haven't
seen what they did oh they're gonna
blast this before
the ice cream truck was was actually
pretty well respected in Baltimore
really it was kind of yeah crazy dude
here's one cool thing bro about four
about four neighborhoods bro [__] could
be whatever dog people be shooting
people yeah
I need a [__] Mario with [__] up
Gumball eyes
[Music]
[Laughter]
everybody has just like a one of those
like little clown faces with the Bubble
Guppies dude absolutely the heart the
hard bubble gum yeah and as soon as the
toughest dude is done eating here this
[__] back back on once once she gets
done with that Flintstone push pop he's
just Red's ready to go yeah you're right
I hope they [__] robots up when they
come if they come through the hood I
hate those things I mean that [__] sucks
well I just don't like it because here's
what I it's like
like it's got a [__] gun dude come on
yeah they're gonna use that to execute
people and like they're trying to make
it dizzy and see if it can still shoot
up Target it's not this is a [__]
robot
I hate this [__] dude this [__] sucks
whoever invented this should be [__]
executed honestly but here's what's
interesting yeah oh that's how does a
robot get uh the ability to do like say
it shows up on a crime scene right yeah
or people are just gonna be like don't
shoot me I'm one of you yeah
I'm not a robot yeah I'm not I don't I'm
fun I'm made of metal too actually
it actually sucks I hate this yeah I
can't believe they got yeah I think that
article is felt I think the article is
fake though I think there's a lot of
fake articles that we don't realize that
are leading to other things yeah
probably especially these days because I
don't know about clicks you just want to
form clicks where you can get as much
traction from something fake if people
dig it I've fallen over fake stuff
before you share something you're like
look at this and people are like that
was debunked years ago yeah yeah you're
like whatever good I take back what I
said about the Jews yeah
like whatever good night
just to not even acknowledging that you
fell for it yeah whatever dude it could
happen to anybody
um what else so were your gr your do you
think of yourself as like
you talk about your weight a lot right
yeah yeah for sure do are you
are you fat or are you just Greek like
that's what I don't know I'm both are
you both I'm both okay yeah or some dual
identity is every Greek person fattest
[__] I don't want to say that is every
Greek person uh
are they larger I feel like if I've seen
a Greek person it seems like a like a
romantic version of you yeah yeah I
there's definitely I definitely hit a
lot is that offensive
okay not at all dude I don't give a [__]
um some people are very like if you go
to Africa right yes
they don't really have the fat guy no no
I don't think so like well they have
apparently there's like one truck like I
saw I as a fat man you read about places
where you know fat people are respected
oh they think and there is one tribe
where the fat guy gets all the [__]
because it's like and they're hilarious
looking too they got these huge [__]
bellies dude and they're not even that
fat the rest of their bodies it's
[__] awesome whatever for whatever
reason that beauty standard there is
like that's it yeah yeah yeah yeah that
first nipple dude that nip that guy
would have an awesome third titty dude
um what else is going on dude uh what
else are we
yeah I feel like do you think when you
think about so you've gotten to see
having some success in like you know
just
um with your stand up right and people
coming to see you which really is
there's rocks with rocks it's every
comedian's dream the whole reason you
started doing like yeah like I mean it's
funny because we all have become
podcasters by accident because it just
like happens to be you know people and
it's a cool way to like you know deal
with your friends at once stay in
people's lives once a week whatever but
it's like I don't know about you but I
just wanted to do stand up like when I
was when I was 19 I just was like
started doing Open Mic so I loved it
yeah it's like all this other [__] is
cool
but it's like that's the thing where I'm
like yeah this [__] rules like that
hour you're on stage is the whole reason
you do it and these theaters are [__]
insane like I can't
like I was talking about when Bert was
on my podcast but it's like oh you
understand why comedians start thinking
they're smart and Geniuses because when
you're in a theater and people like
you're like oh I should be listened to
yeah I'm a I'm a God yeah and it's like
you have to remember that no these
people are they are also just as dumb as
you we're all friends here we're all
dumb friends we're not you know not
we're entertaining we're not smart
that's what I try and remember to remind
myself is that like I'm just trying to
you know yeah and that's the fun thing
is you're just having an awesome time
with a thousand people or whatever the
[__] 500 whatever whatever whatever room
you're in oh yeah and it's the best it
really is it's the whole you know it's
the reason you do anything you know you
did any like stand up to start for me
anyway so these shows have been [__]
out of control
amazing dude yeah it's it's uh
congratulations man thanks man no I
appreciate it it's really really cool
it's [__] wild you very much deserve
a man you're a very and uh you're I mean
you're a really funny guy you're even
making me laugh so much today you're
enjoyable to be around
um and also like it's interesting what
you said about the ego thing right I was
just thinking about this the other day
like my own ego you know and how it
starts to it starts to [__] with you for
sure because you're like
oh I'm good I'm cool yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I mean you know how scary that's
such a scary because you know yeah if
you really like making people laugh and
stuff that's kind of the antithesis of
being connected absolutely it's like and
I mean I think you've done a great job
because like dude your [__] is out of
control like I mean it's awesome it's
like truly there's like people I look at
in the business I'm like yeah I'm trying
to get to those places and like your
shows are wild the podcast is so
successful but you've done a great job
of staying like grounded into who you
are thanks man it's hard it's and it's
and it falters like there's spaces you
know like in my personal life where it's
like I really got to I can feel it when
I'm starting to get like things got
busier recently with like with Tick Tock
really kind of took off and
and that was scary for me because
with Instagram things like we're
doing fine but you kind of were putting
your own stuff out yeah Tick Tock
there's no real like
if like tagging or infringing yeah
societal rules about right it's Anarchy
it is anarchy yeah so suddenly there's
like tons of people seeing you but you
didn't put the stuff out there you
didn't even pick what Clips are going
out right so that's really it feels like
um I get that too because I'm grateful
it's interesting but at the same time
I'm like it's out of your control so
that something having something out of
your control is [__] kind of scary
especially when the nicest and I think
stand-up attracts people like that where
it's like you want Total Control it's
like you're not a team you know what I
mean you go by yourself you even like
even like your own podcast like even
what it's like clearly that means
something to you and I'm the same way I
like to be like in control of what goes
out there but yeah it can be [__]
crazy because yeah your [__] definitely
spread in a way that's like awesome
because it's like next level it's like
what you're talking about is like kind
of getting into the culture in an
organic way yeah and that's cool but
that's like a crazy scary level of like
being like well known which
yeah I I get why that sucks because like
I think about it now where I'm like I
don't want to be like even being this
like whatever famous and I know that I'm
famous
um I just think that like no one looks
like me so if you're even Vaguely
Familiar with me you'll be like hey it's
that it's it's not some other guy with
that hair that's that fat dressed like
that you know what I mean it's like Dom
DeLuise
but that's a crazy thing a lot of older
people think like celebrities never age
and you're like are you dumb pull up Dom
DeLuise
oh yeah he's the man dude yeah he's my
guy and all the Mel Brooks movies my mom
would have totally ask you like is that
dumb is that dumb to always yeah hell
yeah dude he looks awesome is that who
I'm thinking of yeah he's not as fat in
that picture yeah there he is just in
the white hat uh this is I shouldn't
have picked him man
so it's just like an advanced way of
just calling someone fat I feel like he
is my guy though
um he is my guy don't worry about it but
yeah you have a unique look man you're
like yeah Magnum p-i-e
ah I love that that's a good one dude
I've never heard that one though that's
good
that's a horrible man I'm sorry that's
all right you got out of your system you
got any more you got any more you want
to do before we move they have the
n-word in them
I'm keeping those
I'm holding those and hold on to those
dudes yeah not everything's for them
dude something for you too
man you guys are racist
yeah dude it's crazy uh
yeah that's I could see that being
[__] some black guy the other day I
was somewhere and he was like he yells
right it was at a mall I was in Los
Angeles and the Westfield mall and he
keeps yelling man you're my and he kept
yeah he's coming across the mall dude he
said it so many times dude
[Laughter]
yeah in this interaction we're averaging
so many n-words between us even though
he's the one doing all of them he by the
time he got there I was like oh my I
felt like he said it so much that I had
said it yeah exactly dude you were
involved in like a 20 n-word exchange
you know like between the two of you
yeah yeah yeah he had like a uh like an
nr16 or something
firing in
kept getting close
oh my God
my gun word Yeller
lands on me yeah yeah yeah
absolutely people walked up and people
then the white people at you yeah white
people were looking at me like I had
said it yeah go you piece of [__] come
on I have he's my friend yeah I'm better
than you yeah that's what you should
have said when's the last time somebody
called you the n-word that's what you
should have yelled at white people yeah
then get your [__] together
you're not a true Ally unless you've
been called the n-word recently
and I actually kind of believe that too
oh you want to be you want to have
friends you need friends that will call
you that that's true that's what I
remember I think when I was growing up
about the closest thing about it there
was enough of that where I got called it
enough where it was like okay I'm around
at least I can say it now I'm in the
culture yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
you can't yeah it's like you can't say
it yeah yeah but you can you can think
it
bro you can't say you can think it with
sound
but you can't say it
foreign
like do you even think about that kind
of stuff I think because like I love
comedy so it's like I like getting
laughs in every way and I do love
staying like truly stand Up's my first
love I'll never stop doing it right like
even when I'm not good at it anymore
it's like I'll do it for me like I even
when I moved to New York I was like if
this doesn't work I will be one of those
guys that runs a monthly show in his
hometown yeah like just opens at the
club I would never stop doing it
um but you also I don't know if you feel
this way like
you can't really talk about certain
complex things in stand up because at
least if you're good at it you got to
get a laugh every [__] 15 seconds
right like 20 seconds or you feel like
you have to yeah at least I feel like I
have to the way I the what I like about
stand up because I don't like when it
gets too like preachy or pontificating
or any of that [__] so like that's why
I'm interested in like movies and TV uh
because it's like
you get to be funny in different ways
like you know we all have like shows we
love and like movies we love that were
so important to us and it's like yeah
the way I wanted to do stand up because
I like stand up it's like I want to be
funny because I [__] love Eastbound
and Down you know I mean I want to do my
version of [__] Kenny power that
would be [__] awesome you know what I
mean like being like just getting just
being able to like tell a story and like
do different and [__] that your stand-up
has even like touched on but you can do
be a little deeper with it if you write
you know right you can put them into it
or you write a movie you write something
behind it yeah they just had a um who
was that they had that East he had me
thinking of Dan he spanning down he's
Banning Down syndrome they just busted
the guy he's found a Down syndrome would
be an awesome show too K Powers just
developmentally disabled
you see this alleged gang member with
Down Syndrome
and decided on separate Chicago murders
wow
that's kind of on it like let's zoom in
oh damn see this is the kind of thing
and a smoosh they called them smush oh
man that's kind of rude Marie let's zoom
in a little
um can you close out of the video do you
mind just so we can get a little Clarity
here he doesn't seem that
um Nicholas smoosh samudio was indicted
on felony murder charges in the February
16th fatal road rage shooting of
Humberto Mariners they let him drive and
the 20th February 26th slang of Tomas
via damn so he's also he's keeping it in
the community he reportedly killed a man
in front of his pregnant wife oh damn
dude well he might have thought you just
had a really big meal
I don't know if he knows about pregnancy
he's like look at that top tit on hero
hounds doubt though or is he just kind
of a little something's wrong with him
yeah let's see do they say how much he
has
do they have a percentage they covered a
380 caliber handgun with police believe
samudio may have thrown out the window
during the pursuit
um
Is that real do you go up go up all the
way up at the very beginning
just see how they describe him yeah an
alleged gang member with Down Syndrome
wow
a member of the Latin Kings
I mean what is going on oh wait wait
samudio who has been diagnosed with the
genetic disorder according to his public
defender so this might be his lawyer
trying to get him out on
trying to play the r card you know what
I'm saying anyway like the Uno reverse
card he's like let's dance and go yeah
right you know like you let him
right right he's like what's your guy
doing you know I mean he would look I
don't know much about I'm not an expert
but he's driving around
you know what I mean I had a Uber driver
that was uh Down syndrome one time and
he would talk to his mother would tell
him everything to do she was in the she
was on a speaker a call with him yeah no
I swear
really he told him everything to do and
I was in there and I was like this is
just what was his reading like God
working or you know I'm just sitting
here I'm just yeah y'all just using me
today to be a passenger in this guy's
car and I'm gonna bear with it
but that down Center was close man they
thought I had it when I was a kid man
really oh yeah for real well I remember
the doctor telling my mother you know
she wrote it in my baby book
when you were like a baby baby did they
have baby books when you were a kid yeah
and your mom would keep them yep what
was your mom like was she cool she's the
best dude yeah my mom's best really or
Greek mom's good what are they like yeah
truly like my mom is like the
like think about like a classic Eastern
European like mother like just like by
the well yeah yeah yeah yeah if we had a
well she would have been out there
making sure I had water dude like Strega
Nona yeah yeah because that's trigonona
Vibe she has 100 dude uh my mom was just
like you know all we like you come over
to my house you're not leaving without
having a dessert you know what I mean
like I don't want you just like packed a
nice lunch like just so I mean there is
a part of me that's like the reason my
life is the way it is my bet truly my
most cherished childhood memories my mom
was a waitress at a Greek restaurant and
Saturdays she would like come home like
half the time with like leftovers right
like calamari lamb chops whatever I'm
like this fat like a little fat kid lava
yeah sure yeah yeah yeah yeah and uh
actually they had which is like this
cream custard
it's pretty good actually honestly
you're close thank you next time you
yeah it's awesome but she would come
home and I would stay up watching SNL
and it's like The Farley Sandler era
what we're talking about and so it would
be like that's kind of where I Started
Loving comedy was like and it kind of
married my my loves of like comedy
fried foods and like the love of a woman
and it's like now if I think about it
that's what my weekends are except I do
the comedy I get the fried foods and I
try and just like [__] some lady to like
you know fill the hole in my heart you
know what I mean and it's like in some
ways I'm like damn my mom was so like I
loved and waited for my mom so much that
like fully
like the whole course of my life just
because I wanted to see my mom like
waiting for her to get home waiting for
her to get home with some food and I was
like watching comedy until she got home
and it's like sometimes I think like
That's how little control we have over
[__] like that's your Bermuda Triangle
kind of you'll always be in there no
matter what yeah yeah yeah that's really
where I am dude in all every all the
biggest things that have like controlled
my life yeah that's it dude it's like
food truly food addiction is my I'll do
a bunch of drugs I can truly quit them
whenever I can food is so [__] hard
for me uh well yeah and you have to have
food too yes that's the trick about it
if I had to have a little bit of coke
yeah I didn't imagine imagine you have
to do a bump every like eight hours yeah
if say if that every day they gave you a
Coke break from 12 to 1.
yeah there's like a kiosk at the mall
with some girl with big tits with just
lines you can do off them when you
really want to treat yourself yeah you
know what I mean there's like Hibachi
cocaine just some guy
cutting lines with this thing popping
[__] crack rocks in your mouth
you [__] yeah yeah I know it's the
worst one but yeah my mom was truly like
so supportive and I don't know I also
feel like
like the recipe for like an artist too
is like you have to really half hate
yourself and half think you're the man
and it's like my mom is the half that's
like she thought I was like a gene like
she's that kind of mom she's like oh
he's gonna she thought I was gonna be
like the kid that goes to Harvard at 12.
you know what I mean just because I like
she believed in me so much right to the
Moon myself truly like when I was gonna
do stand up she wasn't supportive
because she thought I was like robbing
the world of intellect right like true
that's how much she loved me and
believes that she loved me but she had
all her gauge on you was a little off
yeah I was well because she would take I
was a good student yeah
um I just texted and I'm just joking man
no no no no no no no no she was off
don't get me wrong oh yeah she fully I'm
not like she had utmost but she thought
by stand up you're limited you're
cutting yourself short exactly it took
her a crumb of proof she turned like a
crumb of me being kind of smart into
being like oh he's a generational mind
that we have to like you know that's
gonna like solve world hunger yeah
um but then my dad was the other side
where it's like you know my dad just
like it was not really a you know he was
he was around but not you know didn't
really get the like didn't believe in
you was always kind of worn it was more
like a punitive figure where it's like
hey you better [__] be smarter you'll
end up like me with my [__] like just
telling you how much he hated his life
and it's like oh cool I'm actually
aren't either the part like most of your
life didn't you make all your decisions
to raise me and now me and my brothers
and now you're saying you hate your life
and threaten to kill yourself every six
months so then you learn like oh I guess
by some math you hate us and we're the
reason you want to kill yourself
as a kid you absolutely deduce it oh
yeah no don't show him actually
[Laughter]
him and that lady would have gone along
famously
um is it hard being a Greek man is there
a lot of perils over all of being a
Greek man
um I don't I mean that definitely is The
Stereotype of like you know I mean
everyone I grew up around they all
either were alcoholics or cheated on
their wives you know what I mean there
was no there was no like good Rome a
Greek role model which was really funny
because I met well they took them all
too a long time ago yeah how are you
gonna compete with Socrates Socrates how
are you going to compete with uh Zeus
yeah yeah you know he cheated though he
was that was his thing was cheating
right and he was even our God was
cheating yeah like that's their religion
was like getting side [__] it was like
ancient Greek wisdom
um but no there's no there's no like
it's not hard it's like again I kind of
go back to it kind of cool being Greek
because it's like it's very unique you
get to be white you know what I mean
like in all the things that matter like
cops see me I guess if there's any value
in that yeah yeah
I'm not saying I'm a Believer in that
but you get to seem white yeah yeah you
get to see white in all the ways yeah
you're like Olive Jews yeah
in many ways like grape leaf juice grape
yeah people I've heard people say like
Greeks are like Jews that aren't good
with money you know just like you know
there's a little bit of that for sure
front house juice yeah
absolutely but no I kind of rock I mean
honestly I like it because you get to
just be different enough and I'm trying
to also stay connected to that [__] too
because it's hard in America it's like
you see different like cultures
that [__] disappears in a couple
Generations so fast here so fast like
especially if you're just like oh if
you're just like a white ethnicity it's
like in two generations it's like you
just have like you know my kid might
like so I think about that now because
like you're I'm 34. it's like I'm
getting there where it's like I'm a full
there's no more like oh when I grow up
it's like I'm a [__] grown man you
know but like especially when you do
stand up you can convince yourself like
you're still young it's like you know oh
it happens yeah we're knocking on the
door so I'm starting to think about that
[__] so but it's cool I get I go to
Greece I visit my I have family over
there I still speak Greek I want to like
you know yeah so it's like my goal would
be to spend three months a year in
Greece and just like [__] chill out
dude you know speak the language eat
some [__] calamari oh yeah
and do they um
do Greek women like you are you a Greek
woman kind of do you like Greek women I
you again part of like getting older I'm
like I find myself
attracted like Greek and being like it
would actually be cool to be with a
Greek one just because we share those
like yeah that culture and the you know
a language all that kind of [__]
um I've never dated a Greek girl I've
I'm attracted to features that I think
Greek like I like curly hair I like uh
you know tan yeah I like a big nose you
know what I mean like I like a man yeah
yeah
hey let's get let's get you a perm bro
and I'm in there damn dude um but I've
never been with I've never dated a Greek
girl wow yeah maybe God's saving that
for you for the end that would be nice
you know that would be nice you could be
like you're the first Greek girl I ever
dated yeah do you think that you could
fall in love do you think it's hard for
a comedian to fall in love yeah I think
so I mean I don't know how you feel but
it's like
like
it's cool to like get to travel and like
[__] a bunch of strangers you know like
that part is nice but at a certain point
first of all yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know you also sound like the
Golden State rapist
it's cool state to state no trail of
evidence behind me by the time the cops
know what's up I'm [__] gone that
part's cool
[Laughter]
by the time they file a police report
I'm in Ottawa
I'm across state lines I'm across cult
you know I'm across the border
[Laughter]
um sorry go on but yeah I feel like I'm
tired of that like you do start to get a
little tired of like even when you get
the [__] and just like girls that are
much too hot for you which you know I
mean for it's like it's cool I've gotten
if I've gotten I've gotten to experience
some pretty cool stuff yeah but but you
know but after a certain point you're
like oh it would be nice to just have
someone you care about and like put
effort into that relationship instead of
like just
right just throwing a ball against a
wall all the time exactly exactly it'd
be nice to throw it to somebody and they
catch it exactly yeah
yeah playing cash with like no father
right emotionally I feel like that robot
yeah exactly exactly it's a robot
um so I think I'm gonna but it is hard
on this schedule I don't think I could
have dated someone it's hard
and your brain reads your brain's like I
forgot about that you know yeah I come
home I forget that I it's hard it's uh
because I don't think your brain a human
brain isn't supposed to be different
places in different days like we're not
even supposed to be flying yeah this
much and they should say that when you
get on yeah
this is an affront to God and if we make
it we're on borrowed time you're one
step closer to death the next one yeah
that's what they should say at the
beginning of every flight
if we if we make it we have deceived God
and he's a vengeful God and he will get
us eventually I love him yeah
it's turbulence happens and people are
shocked like yeah yeah
we're flying isn't it crazy there's not
turbulence constantly we're in the
[__] sky going so [__] fast
there's more turbulence on uh like a
street in New Orleans right yeah yeah
potholes on a white Street in New
Orleans yeah there's seven thousand
times
and it's more dangerous to [__] drive
a car statistically but that's what they
say but that Airlines made that up
that's a good point they obviously
yeah dude they were on euronews.next I'm
talking about no you're much it's much
safer in the sky
you should you should ride a helicopter
to work yeah
oh
what was it whenever you was going to
school do you remember like your first
girlfriend growing up
um dude I was so I was so like
shy when it came to like because I was I
had this big outsized personality and
that like
I I never got nervous in any social
situation
and then except girls hey so it was like
this weird thing where it's like
everyone loved me and everyone assumed I
like I could talk girls into whatever
but it's like because that was
nerve-wracking it was the only time I
ever experienced anxiety like social
anxiety so it made it impossible so like
I didn't have like a girlfriend like I
hooked up with a couple girls in high
school but I didn't get [__] like I
didn't [__] till College yeah and it
wasn't until like I like put in the time
and like felt comfortable with somebody
and that I could like say my feelings I
was so scared of just like I don't know
ridicule or I don't know what it was so
in in high school I had like one one
girl one girlfriend who just who I like
I touched her breasts like twice and she
might have [__] like six guys like in
that time frame you know what I mean she
was like it was one of those where she
was yeah hurry up and touch my tits I
can go [__] you yeah yeah get me warmed
up
it was one of those things where she
would call me and like we would call
we'd talk on the phone it was one of
those relationships and she lived in a
different part of the town a different
part of town and it was like you know
before I even had a driver's I had my
permit and then it was like I got my
license I went to a couple parties that
she was at we made out a couple times
and then she called me she was like Hey
I accidentally Got Fingered uh last
night and I'm like okay
um well don't let it happen again you
know and then she she called me like
three she got accidentally figured like
three more times and I was like you know
what I I don't know that this is gonna
work out like I broke up with her she
clearly was like wasn't even dating me
effectively we weren't dating I would
like call her but she would [__] other
guys and she'd even touch my dick I
touched her tits like two or three times
it sounds like you have arrested him I
have a real resentment towards are still
to this day resentment is a big problem
I have for sure is it really yeah yeah I
don't like I have a hard time letting
things go I'm a grudge keeper is that a
great characteristic I think it is wow I
think it and like definitely there's
anger problems in my like that runs in
my family I'm something I'm working on
like I'm on there I'm in therapy or
anger specifically uh anger is one of
the big ones yeah for sure anger I mean
my dad had an anger problem the wheel
just kind of inherited and like uh anger
and then guilt also or like my big ones
yeah immigrant [__] guilt is huge dude
because it's like your parents are like
well I came to this [__] country so
you would have a better life that like
my dad would drop that he's like I hate
it here I want to be in Greece you know
meanwhile the [__] his life would have
been dog [__] in Greece but right my dad
was crazy my dad grew up in Nicaragua
when he was until he was like 12 or
something and they had kids eating dirty
said in his village they'd have kids
with like distended bellies just worms
in their bellies yeah he said from just
eating dirt and stuff but then he'd be
like go get me some mayonnaise you know
and that was it he never like he never
told me like a lot of stuff you know I
would just kind of watch him from afar I
guess yeah yeah
um well that makes sense too because
it's like that's a different kind of
immigrant where it's like where you're
if you're leaving a place with like
they're eating dirt like you want to be
in America whereas like you know my dad
like didn't want to be in America he
claimed he didn't want to anyway right
you know
um but I think both of them sound like
they weren't very the salary that was
very emotionally open didn't sound like
there's a lot sharing going on yeah I
don't think so and I think you get older
at a certain point you kind of lose the
space it's almost like you almost have
to share your emotions in a certain time
period it feels like because I feel like
sometimes maybe I wonder if I wonder if
you lose an emotional connection like
sensibility once you get past a certain
age I never thought of I never really
heard about that but that'd be
interesting I bet you you relate to
things differently yeah you know but I
could also see it almost go in the
opposite way where it's like the older
you get you kind of like shed a little
bit of that like whom I even protect
what am I pretending yeah you know I
definitely feel myself getting a little
more open and just more like like
whatever catch the [__] because I'm just
like I don't give a [__] right what are
these resentments yeah they'll fall away
yeah a little bit yeah those I'm still
holding on to yeah I still have a couple
enemies yeah you know a couple people
who who every day I think about like how
much better my life is going than theirs
and I'm like awesome like I was just
like it's so just like that's awesome
dude [__] that guy he [__] me and like
my [__] is going so I'm lapping him ten
thousand like I still have one I still
indulge in just a little bit of that you
know just like um
to pick your teeth yeah yeah but for the
most part I also think you you realize
what the problems are in your life and
you don't let those people in your life
anymore you're more aware of those
people you're aware of the patterns of
the people you don't want to be around
and like now everyone I'm around it's
like I work with my best friends like I
hired my best friends to like be my
Purdue my best friend oh yeah I met your
friend what's his name oh Ben yeah Ben
yeah yeah Ben's the man dude shout out
to Benny butt cheeks Ben O'Brien Ben
O'Brien bring him up let's get let's get
a gander out yeah yeah he has a train
conductor Vibe huh he does he loves he
loves overalls he loves overalls I love
him dude no Ben rocks uh and Ben yeah
Ben works for me and then yeah there he
is and uh and then I go yeah yeah he he
was a part of like an awesome comedy
Collective William City uh he was like
an art he went to art school did like
his own he kind of has that Boo Radley
smarter brother Vibe yeah he's
definitely yes absolutely yeah he's more
in touch with this [__] more emotional
uh on his own little journey just
figuring his [__] out because we all
went to to um Paris Paris that was fun
that was that was a sick that was an
awesome time bro remember they put us in
that plane the jet was insane God that
thing was nice dude that was all I mean
we had a great crew it was so nice bro
sometimes I remember I'll be in hotel
rooms and it's like it's like 400 500 a
night dude I ain't even sleeping in that
[__] yeah yeah staying awake I'm
getting my money's worth
yeah dude sitting on the couch you got a
sweet so you just sitting on the couch
even though you're tired you're like no
I'm sitting on this couch yeah I had I
was in a [__] Holiday Inn Express of
four years ago I'm hanging out in the
suite I'm putting [__] in the mini
fridge even if I don't drink it yeah I'm
just getting this [__] cold yeah yeah
I'm putting my ID in there so I'll pick
it up in the morning it's [__]
freezing I don't used to have a mini
fridge and [__] hotel money
yeah man it's something about it it's
like oh I'm not yeah I'm not sleeping
it's gonna cost me seventy dollars
you're out of here
I'm gonna walk around this half living
room I love the half living room I've
become such a [__] half living room
like [__] Diva dude I love the I
gotta get the half living room for what
I don't know but I gotta have it you got
it it's like dude Hotel it's like they
give you half of every room yeah
one room I know I know
um it's like the Power Rangers like they
all got together we're like this is yes
you know it's like yeah the the it's all
the different ones the last what the
[__] was that called the last Mohicans
maybe no Zordon was their [__] leader
oh are you talking about what was it
called when they got together
uh are you talking about the Brooklyn
Nets yeah Kyrie Hardin Kyrie Hardin and
Kevin Durant I'm thinking about the
Brooklyn Nets I'm not sure if now since
disbanded
um yeah dude
it's like Diddy's Making the Band
bro bad that band was they made it was
the band was horrible but it was a good
show yeah the show we made him get
Cheesesteak your cheese steaks they made
him walk to Philly or whatever the [__]
he made him do bro they didn't do it he
didn't take them anymore
he basically got five brothers and
sisters I know I made him walk six miles
to get him a dessert but at least it was
almost like a story out of the Bible
everything was it felt more like a
parable
in the future that's what people look
back remember 700 years ago yeah you
know when Bonnie had to [__] you must
go to Juniors for cheesecake and what
did we learn and you must not be tempted
by the evils of Dylon you must be true
to Diddy no matter what the temperature
is Dylon says to you
at least we got the Chappelle show skit
too we got a couple nice cultural
artifacts from that but yes no good
music yeah the music was dog [__]
Chopper he was pretty good yeah Chopper
was good man he was out of New Orleans I
think he fell for the ladies too much
though what else what we got in the news
man let's get a couple of news topics
and you got your special and it's out
tomorrow tomorrow yeah uh four nights in
New York it's on my YouTube channel and
the fat Rascal tour I'm coming all over
the place I'm going to cleave like just
I'm doing a bunch of fall dates they're
selling well it's big theaters so it's
like I'm a little nervous but they're
selling pretty good you know but it's
one of those things where when you do
small shows and sell them out you feel
good but we have these like big rooms
and you're like [__] I hope this just
keeps selling at this time oh it's so
scary and almost that almost became too
scary for me
um it's one I it becomes okay I had a
real problem with that yeah and I still
do sometimes it's like I'm afraid yeah
it's like the last there's something
inside of me the last thing I want man
this is crazy I didn't really realize
this
is the there's a huge fear that
somebody's not going to show up for me
yeah yeah so and it doesn't mean like
actual people buy it's not but it's like
goes back to like being a child it's
like somebody's not gonna be there oh
dude absolutely so if I put you put
something out there you're basically
opening and saying hey will you be here
for me and it's kind of different
because it's a transactional thing and
it's but it's still the same like
concept no I get it you're putting
yourself out especially when it's like
one level higher than you're used to and
it's like you're when when you're
putting yourself when you're at risk
right when you've made yourself
vulnerable and then you're like oh
I know I could have done this smaller
place but it's like I hope all these
people that it seems like are there are
going to show up and then if they don't
yeah it feels [__] horrible but
things are going good so far yeah you
can knock on wood oh man you're so funny
they definitely will continue to go good
I think I I um
yeah I noticed even more on that topic
that
yeah I commit to my like work is my
biggest relationship because it's like
the safest most controlled place to even
be vulnerable I fully I I felt that
happening where it was like which is a
little scary right because you're like
you stop being a person and you just
become like oh yeah I've just gotta keep
crushing this because this is this is
going good I know I can control this I
have full control over it
um and you start like like I started
feeling like depressed when I had time
off when I but while I was in it I was
like I can't wait for some time off need
a couple days off I'm [__] run down
and then you get it and you're like
what the [__] do I even do like you know
what I mean it's like you don't have the
other so I was like and I felt and then
when I went back to work even though it
was like like I had a month I had a like
a stretch where I was on the road like
seven weeks in a row and the one week I
had off I had to do a different trip and
it was like just too much
but when it starts you're like at least
I know what I have to do there's no
ambiguity right there's no think you
know if you're like me there's like no
your own thoughts you don't even have
time to think because it's like I have
to be on the road every weekend I have
to podcast at some point but you know in
between that and then you know you have
to do
[__] YouTube videos where all this
other [__] and it's like there is
something freeing to not having to make
a decision but then at the same time and
there's something that feels awesome
where it's all going good right you see
the [__] the numbers go up and the
feeling you know feeling of success
but that is a little like that's that
could be a trap too because yeah some of
the [__] you can't have control of
that's that's the scary thing it's like
yeah you gotta kind of put yourself you
gotta have that vulnerability with just
the person or people in your life or
like some other [__] that's just not
work
um yeah I think when I was a kid I think
I take everything back when I was a kid
I'm like I love just you know walking
through my own haunted house of course
of course yeah oh that's gone yeah
that's going for good
you're on Columbus once you are you know
but yeah I think that like uh
just uh
going back in in
until like yes somebody gonna be there
is am I gonna be like I think wanting to
be seen too why you even end up doing it
you know yeah yeah why do I need to
go have people
show me that they see me and I think
comedy it's like show me you see me in a
very real way it's like I need proof I
need audible yeah I need to see it and I
need to hear it right right and I did
every 15 seconds and I need it to be
undeniable and that's one thing I think
about if somebody's laughing it's kind
of if they're genuinely laughing it's
undeniable absolutely so it's like I
need I don't trust things enough in the
space that I'm in or in the like home
space I'm in that I need undeniable
proof that you see me absolutely yeah
and it has to be almost from like a
cellular level so that's why it has to
be right involuntary right laughter is
the one like involuntary thing where
it's like yeah you even if you're trying
not to laugh
you'll still laugh if it's [__] if
something hits you just right oh yeah
it's just like a fee it's like feelings
just farting right out of your skin yeah
yeah
enjoy feelings feelings yeah yeah yeah
um let's get into a little bit of news
man you got a few more minutes he's
actually uh Starbucks does a Advice Line
show so we didn't know if you wanted to
do a couple voicemails together oh I
would love that yeah stavy's world we do
have to show his advice so I'd love to
help the love to help the fam out all
right let's bring it up so Savvy you
have on your show you have yeah stavy's
world we do half voicemails so it's like
we bring somebody on and next time you
know come anytime you want come to the
show for sure it's been so much fun man
yeah dude we just [__] around for the
first half out for the first 45 minutes
of the show and then we do advice and
people just call in with all types of
[__] so praise yeah stabby's world we
got we got two episodes a week one free
one patreon so yeah dude yeah so I'd
love to I'd love to help some of the
[__] let's see what we got here play
it up brother kind of like a call back
to a classic that was on the show we'd
like to get like gestavros's take on it
okay okay
Theo
um
I'm calling I have I work in a uh
Learning Center okay and these past few
weeks I've been having
there's just been I work with special ed
kids and uh you know it's yeah it's it's
a job it gets stuff done but recently
there's been a kid named James he has
autism
and
uh recently he's been trying to
uh
sexually assault me
and you know I don't really care but
it's more frightening for the other
students
and
the thing is you know
I know they can't help it and stuff but
every time he does it he just has this
look in his eyes
this lustful evil look
stop that James stop it James please
stop what's he doing you know he'll be
helicopter in it and it's just
helicopter
and we're a little yeah we're a little
afraid for our safety okay that's it no
way this isn't [__] real that sounds
real to me you don't think that that's
real hell this kid's pulling his [__]
out and flipping it around what would
you do if you pulled your [__] out
I guess I would give it an up and I
order another full helicopter maybe
that's a that's a size issue maybe this
autistic kid's got a nice [__] piece
and he's really letting it hang I would
go up and down just because the
helicopter's not as impressive when the
when the circumference of the helicopter
when it's like a mini
like a hummingbird
it's more of a drone
[Laughter]
oh and yeah I think oh I think the first
thing you do if you've already exposed
your penis you have to then and then you
realize okay this is weird I don't know
what you need an emotion I think you
have to spin your penis okay that's fair
and this kid's doing it on a primal
autistic level too he's just kind of
connected it's like he's not thinking
he's just pulling his dick great limbic
system it's like very much yes yes if
you are uh you see this a lot on nature
Channel yeah you know where the monkey
or kind of or the uh the way a monkey
uses penis this kid probably uses his
penis yeah or a grasshopper or something
or like a uh one of those little like uh
lizards or something they'll clean off
all the area around them and then
they'll make their thing real big like
this they'll make their little like uh
like a mating like a hat kind of it's
like okay part of the back just like a
fake hat pops out behind their head
and it's like red and blue yeah yeah
yeah but I think everybody has their
mating call and you say you think this
kid's pulling his penis out is his
mating call I think what else would it
be
if you're autistic
I don't still have very that's the thing
I think everybody's gotta worry
everybody has Primal needs man yeah it
doesn't even matter I would think okay
so if you're if he's really this horny
is this dick hard
and once you think it's hard you're not
really in the helicopter Zone
I wonder if autism can get an erection
oh I think they can you think oh yeah
I think they could probably get real
nice ones because they're not in up in
their head like we said it's limbic oh
yeah I have some anxiety problems
sometimes my dick's not getting hard
because I'm you know nervous yeah this
kid's not nervous especially if his dick
is out in math class you know he's like
overridden yeah his dick has overridden
his feeble autistic mind yeah and just
gotten hard like with well you know this
root is square yeah
I don't think I think this guy's lying
though it's at least a rectangle
cylinder what about uh you think this
has a line I think so he he wow it's
funny because yeah I I I I didn't think
I could feel a smile on his lips it's I
could say I could hear the smile on his
lips yeah you could be right
I just feel like if a kid is pulling his
dick out in a special ed first of all it
has there's no way it doesn't happen
well it happens in regular head
if somebody tells you you're special
you're definitely gonna pull your dick
out
I feel like it's the first thing you do
so okay so maybe though but you're not
though so maybe they've misdiagnosed him
maybe this is a form of rebellion
although he's he claims he's got an evil
lustful look in his eyes and he says
he's sexually assaulting him which means
he thinks the kid is trying to rape him
or I think he said the kid has a look in
his eyes and the kid is trying to be
sexually deviant right but I believe
that the kid is just trying to advance
sexually now let's how about this
isn't this a perfect place for sex
robots
because you don't want to Jack the kid
off that smallest station right yeah but
if there is a in fact sex robots and
special in like high school special ed
that might be the place they're most
needed
just get them
you know what I mean clear their brains
they're up against enough challenges
learning how to read already you don't
want them hard too
they should have you should have to milk
every special ed kid before you start a
lesson I've actually flipped completely
on this I think this is the natural way
to deal with this we need those Chinese
dick sucking machines that Jordan
Peterson retweeted I don't know if you
saw that yeah
yeah yeah I think you gotta if you bring
in robots just for a sec yeah I wonder I
don't know I think you almost have to
have a parent of a child like this they
would have to sign a permission slip for
sure that's what I'm saying you can't
just I think send a robot in there or be
like hey who's got 50 cents you know
it's in the hole
I think a gumball machine
yeah
[Laughter]
let us all out to get a candy every now
and then
you're actually you know what that's
true the school nurse has to I think you
have to have someone there because they
it can't be because if it was like but
then are you teaching a autistic kid
sorry I stepped on you going no no no no
no no no please are you T I don't know
but is it Pavlov's dog now are they
going to get horny every time they learn
a new fact
you know you've taught them to evacuate
their nuts before learning that's a good
point that's a yeah and then you might
have to do the opposite you listen all
day
we let this robot suck your dick
you know I can't throw about this
masturbating like that yeah yeah yeah I
guess you're right you can jack him I
feel like if I have autism and you put
your I just like the uh the sensory
overload yes
of a robot like you know
yeah it would be more of a jacking off
thing and it wouldn't look like a woman
we want this to feel medical okay we
want to just be a whole you put your
your special penis inside of and it just
drains you and put gets you in the mind
frame for learning docile you know
yeah ready to learn
honestly that's crazy brother
yeah I feel like I would learn I would
have learned a lot better in high school
if they like somebody jacked me off
right before you would have been you
would have just gotten in line over and
over again yeah that's true you would
have missed every class well that's why
I should be controlled you'd had a book
bag full of dried out semen
you would still be in school there
I'm in Community College I've been
continuing education
wait 19 pounds you'd have no
you have nothing left in your body
yeah that's true you're right let's get
uh let's see what other news we got it's
not a perfect solution
but yeah at that age man that's tough oh
it would be just
it would be a lot huh I just remember
specific lessons I probably missed
because I was thinking about sex so much
yeah my tea I had a hot teacher you know
what I mean think about getting oh yeah
we had a lady when she would come over
I would say I don't know what this is
right and she would come over and I
would be so just caught up with like the
smell of her and like and even just her
possible tits like and she had like nine
layers of clothing she had like clothing
from like the 1600s she had all of that
with the color frilly collar oh
definitely she had bra over bra under
Pro you know yeah yeah she had her tit
she had an underbite on her kid she had
every yeah thing you could have right as
much as you could you know yeah and uh
you could still feel her tits her tit
meet sometimes being closer to radiating
through all that clothing oh dude
believe me I had it one of my kids in
sixth grade you just wanted to get in
humongous fake titties oh fake ones yeah
oh they didn't allow them at our school
I remember that it was natural you only
had natural hair big natties to teach
they did a silicon they did a [__] uh
they put her through an MRI make sure
there's no they make sure there's no
silicone in those titties the the
principal's like okay checks out things
feel good but back then dude they had
the one you could tell if that's true
the Technology's gotten really nice it
looked like everyone looked like
somebody had vacuum sealed a couple
chicken cutlets
they were a little too heavy you could
see exactly where they yeah they were so
tight I was like man this thing this
lady to my knowledge had pretty awesome
tits
um like you could she didn't wear she
didn't have like multiple layers she was
putting them out there like she would
look at me wrong you wouldn't see
cleavage but it would be like one of
those things which like a just a tight
t-shirt oh man she has big old titties
yeah this lady I wanted to drive right
through her tits with a small car
a Geo Metro driving geometrics yeah yeah
and I would have left the windows down
and just
oh yeah
well another another I remember speaking
of just being in proximity of titties or
hot girls or whatever how exciting dude
my neck would turn red if I got around
some tits yeah I was like oh my [__]
God I remember when I was like in fifth
grade I had to wear a scarf for like
three months dude because I was just so
horny
because I remember the blood would like
it would just
you had an anti-erection scarf
you just remember
the blood would come to the edge of my
skin yeah yeah oh it was like get me out
of here
oh man I remember I because I had I had
a full beautiful head of hair in high
school I had this this hair length but
it was like even longer and like curlier
and nice and you know my school my high
school was like
um uh it was like you know most it was
like 85 black or 90 black yeah and then
of course Greek we I was cool I was like
I was on the football team I was a fun
funny guy you know whatever I was
hanging out and uh and girls would just
love to just play with uh your curly
white hair you know what I mean they
would girls would love to like braid my
hair and I just remember just like just
feeling the warmth of a [__] like when
a girl was like standing over you yeah
but no I mean like oh you feel uh yeah
this girl almost had a heater I don't
know what was going on she had a little
convection oven oh yeah between her legs
and I remember feeling beat oh yeah on
my neck and I was like it's a real thing
look up uh
[Laughter]
the um
is the vagina warmer oh for sure at we
can't say it in children
[Laughter]
whatever what you look up dude
because I don't think you can do stuff
like that yeah no I but I think probably
when you're just joking
and for the record I was 16 she was 16.
yeah and everybody even in my
imagination right now is it's 38 years
old
are we gonna go to jail bro no you
didn't search it so we're good did you
search it no when is the vagina warmest
was the closest I was willing to get to
okay that could be time of day
okay let's see what it says
or maybe we shouldn't it sounds like
uh vaginal temperature indicative of
thermal uh
is winter vagina a real thing let's look
at that
maybe this will get us out of trouble
to put it mildly not all experts are
convinced it's a real problem
what's going on here uh this is very
bloggy the vagina maintains a steady
temperature and human body temperature
only Rises with the outside temperature
when someone is suffering from heat
stroke maybe this girl was out in the
sun too long
because I do remember uh just an
emanating [__] oh I remember being
around a woman's vagina dude and just
the first time you even like well I
remember the first time even like a girl
allowed yeah allowed you to put your
deviant
criminal
perverted [__] claws on her yeah yeah
yeah yeah and how every part of her body
was like a and you would touch anything
yeah it would be like whoa what's going
on here oh just put your elbow in like
yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah I remember being so excited
brother just to be alive and be touch
woman but I do remember around there
like
Uber or whatever that it would be warmer
yeah or it would seem more it could have
been in your brain it could have been
your brain because it's been how bad you
wanted access to some [__] because you
felt like like the uh uh briefcase in
Pulp Fiction were just oh yeah like
that's what [__] was in your head was
just like sometimes it's like warm yeah
oh yeah sure there's been plenty of
those oh the briefcase we're leaving
here
but all right we changed around and
thrown in the ocean
remember yeah man it would just you
would be so
I mean just geeked up
I mean it was like even if a woman
wasn't gonna let you touch her but even
just that the fact that she let you put
her hands all right first time just
being around a damn titty I remember
putting my ear up to it
this girl that was like the first girl I
ever even dated in
out of Summer putting my ear up too and
then hearing the ocean
no I think I even remember this is kind
of crazy but I think I even remember
doing like the Pledge of Allegiance
that would make me patriotic the first
time I see tits
that's a beautiful moment
I mean that's awesome
that's breast autism I mean it's like I
think it's as close as you can get
probably
knowing that you have these feelings and
they are just
they take you over yeah that's the thing
yeah for sure
I mean I remember just the first time uh
when you guys made love where was it in
a in an apartment like a dorm first time
I got [__] was in a dorm that's
beautiful but it was nice it was cool
because it was like she my college
girlfriend wanted to kind of like wait
and she was like all right well you know
I had gotten jacked off I had gotten I
think she blew me and it was like she's
like all right well now you can go down
on me I was like great and uh she just
uh she I ate her [__]
I licked recruiters
I tickled her cooter
and uh I remember being like feeling
proud of myself because her plan was to
just let me lick her color over Cube and
she was like you know what maybe we
could just have sex right now she said
that yeah she's like let's just [__] it
out and it was like and like let's have
sex now and I was like real nice and it
was oh it was like incredible and I was
just like I can't this is incredible
like I felt like I earned my natural
[__] eating abilities I hadn't eaten I
think that's the first time I ate a girl
out like I had like fingered a girl
before right right right but I'd never
like and when you was it daytime or was
it daytime yeah first time I had sex was
like uh it was like 11 A.M it was it was
like it was like [__] Price is Right
is on bro imagine I think I literally
went to like lunch with like
like a like a family friend afterwards I
think it was like we were she was over
my in my dorm and it was like what do
you what'd you do this what are you up
to today they were just talking about
[__] and I was just like like I think it
was like a guy was trying to get an
internship with yeah like right I busted
the first time inside a woman ever and
I'm this guy's talking to me about like
Greektown development yeah and I'm like
I don't give a [__] about any of this
yeah like I'm having a kid in nine
months
it was in a concert
where this apartment complex goes
let's get some more news on what else is
going on out there I'm trying to think
of what happened I don't even know dude
I haven't been well they had this beer
the beer all this a lot of stuff with
trans activism you know shout out to
them yeah and it's got to be uh but what
is it what is being trans yeah I mean I
know it's like
is it
I know it's men or women who want to be
the other right yeah or they feel stuck
inside of the they feel wrong fully
convicted yeah I think that's a good way
to put it convicted in the wrong body
right that's what it seems like to me
anyway although some people just want to
go I'm neither I'm non-binary you know
I'm throwing on some overalls I'm just
hanging out I'm getting honestly a
haircut a lot like yours that's like so
many lessons yeah yeah but I think
Mullen is a pretty nice non-binary
look yeah do you think what do you think
because there's a lot of companies now
that are advertising stuff right I mean
this is hilarious Kid Rock it's just
[__] chill out Kid Rock got me Kid
Rock but he's also Kid Rock I know you
know I'm like [__] Anheuser-Busch have a
terrific day well you really showed them
buying their [__] and shooting it with
guns and then basically giving them a
giving them an advertisement
like everyone who likes trans people is
going to be like damn Kid Rock's dumb
I'm gonna get some Bud Light
know there's been but kid apparently
grew up rich
he uh that's kind of wild grip at least
middle class yeah yeah his family had a
car dealership I think oh okay nice yeah
I think I think the thing about it I
think is that he's the place that he's
coming from is
do
are they trying like
what is I just wonder what is the biz
what is is there a business goal of it
does it seem
that's what I'm just curious about it
because it seems like an interesting
move yeah yeah yeah I see that's the
thing that's what I think has kind of
been blown kind of crazily out of
proportion is like trans people that I
know they just want to be trans right
they don't they just want to like not be
like kill like because that's the thing
as a if you're like going M to like M to
F if you were like born a man you
transition to female it's like that's
like a lot of them like become sex
workers a lot of them like get like
violence against them guys who feel like
they've been either tricked or like
whatever and it's like scared it's like
a pretty scary thing to you know it's a
pretty like tough lifestyle and they're
just like hey I just want like not to be
killed and to be like basically
respected and to be able to go to like
the doctor and I just don't it's such a
low percentage of people too that's
what's crazy to me that we're having
this discussion that's the part to me is
interesting it's such a small and I
wonder are you helping trans people by
like Bud Light like is this the move to
help
because I I totally understand what
you're saying like imagine if you are if
you feel that way right imagine if you
really feel it right yeah now I think
there's a big there could be a
difference between people who really
feel it and also now if they're
commercializing it or if they're
sensationalizing it so much that a mind
that isn't sure now adapts to it to like
have a cause because people will can
grasp onto a lot of causes right for
sure and I think like
I think like with any kind of thing that
gets a lot of publicity you will have
people that are like
just unsure will like reach on to it and
you will have here's the thing with
anything that gets any traction you'll
get people doing it cynically to get
famous right right but the way that
there's like it's like a one percentage
of people are trans
point zero zero one of them are like
these weird people doing it for
attention right you know so it's like
that's what it's crazy about these
discussions is like for the most part
what we're talking about is like let
people have jobs you know like just let
them have basic and the way I look at it
right is like just let them go about
their lives without facing
discrimination and like who gives a [__]
yeah what do you care if somebody like
was born a guy wants to chop their dick
off and be a girl yeah why does that
bother you and I do find it a little
ironic where it's like especially people
that are talking about like you know
like
not to get super political with it but
it's like the states that are very anti
the trans [__] it's like you have people
talking about how they want limited
government but then they're like oh I
have to check your daughters to see if
your daughter has a vagina before like
Florida was talking about a bill where
they're tracking girls periods to prove
their their to prove their biological
female it's like like a white bracelet
or something yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah a hoop trap Florida yeah Ron
DeSantis wanted one around like teen
girls yeah
inside of them and it's like aren't you
supposed to be the one for like limited
government but we're checking girls
period it's just like or they made it
like illegal to mention it period it's
like dude it's [__] crazy and I'm
just like I don't get like I have
something I don't understand why it's a
bit like if someone's trans let them be
trans like I would never be upset at
anybody that's trans or like I would be
very curious what it's really like for
sure I would be very curious in today's
world what if someone is like just gay
and they see an option to be for a clout
or just totally uh straight and season
it because there's such a me it's such a
like yeah like you know a currency out
there now that I could see that being
some but I don't say that to diminish it
because those people are also
diminishing if people are really dealing
with that like for sure I don't know I
guess I guess I just wonder is this the
best person to introduce that
to the work like because a lot of people
now are just starting to talk about
trans which is maybe is good but it's
also such a small percentage of people I
guess I just don't understand
well is this going to be helpful to
trans people because it almost
like if I'm a trans person right and my
life is tough right yeah if I really am
if I because I believe that you know I
mean you makes God makes so many cookies
man you could yeah yeah yeah yeah
something or nature could be also
merging you don't know yeah and I also
think in like other societies like
ancient ones people were kind of like in
between genders and other sites had like
multiple genders yeah look at Robin Hood
yeah exactly those guys are in Tights
come on you tell me you know somebody
somebody threw on made Marion's dress
Big John was a bear dude yeah
but I just want I guess I wonder if
we're like say like a regular trans
person who does not want the wild
attention right and who just is trying
to figure out their thing do they think
that this is I wonder if this is feels
comfortable to them that now it's this
thing it's like attached to be it's like
yeah I don't know I know you mean like
it's become like a uh like um well
anytime like advertising or whatever you
know when you become super mainstream
but I think a lot of the attention is
unwanted I think for the most part but I
do think it's because it's like kind of
a political backlash because I think
I think of what
I don't want to get [__] super
political here right yeah maybe we are
getting but but there is something to a
culture War thing where conservatives
have been very shrewd starting with like
Karl Rove where it was like
um they it started with gay marriage
right and it's like because people are
like like [__] sucks in America for a
lot of poor people but I think when you
don't when you don't want to offer poor
people anything in terms of like
material help in terms of like better
schools better you know Healthcare like
healthcare is a big issue right like
people are [__] and everything's
getting more privatized and there's less
like support
I think the way that you uh that you get
people to like vote for you is you like
rile them up and scare them whether that
and like there's this big backlash
against trans people because I think
it's become a conservative Boogeyman
where they're talking about like you
know drag queens and they're talking
about how drag queens are gonna like
groom your like they're calling gay
people groomers and [__] and I think
that's really dangerous and I think that
attention has come because trans people
are being used as a political tool in
the negative whereas like I mean dude
it's so funny to hear people talk about
how drag queens are like you know oh
they're so dangerous for kids where it's
like drag queen like you think they
molest P like politicians and Priests
are up two million kids to zero on yeah
that's the drag queens it's like you
know maybe a thousand maybe like a
thousand yeah yeah maybe there's one
yeah there's one of them whatever but
it's like still drag queens are gonna
start having to do like flea flickers
and like trick plays to get back in the
game yeah
compared to politics they're the ones
[__] kids and it's like it's just
become this political Ploy you know yeah
it's like yeah that's it I mean look
that's a that's a really great Point man
I think what I hear a lot of times that
people are scared of especially on the
backs of like the vaccine and stuff like
that people are scared that
well is this some another reach where
they're trying to where the media will
then use like a lot of like film
television exposure about gender
uncertainty and then to start to get you
young people to want to take like a
gender blocker right or some type of a
medicine right and I don't know enough
about the medicine yeah yeah but I think
as when I look even how influenced I was
I mean I watched WWE wrestling yeah if
the rock cut his dick off you'd be
thinking about it dude if somebody threw
my grandmother against the if somebody
just threw my grandmother against the
ropes yeah I would have kicked that
bitch's head off
that's how influenced I was by WWE yeah
absolutely it was over bro no amount of
calcium pills was gonna bring her back
yeah so I think that's a lot of people's
fear it's like man there's so much
influence over my children that
if they start to use this chip are they
then just going to come in with another
medicine on the back of covid where a
lot of people are skeptical about the
vaccine now sure and rightfully so yeah
so I think that's probably a lot of I
think that's a lot of the fear yeah but
but I think the the molestation part
you're right it's like yeah it's like oh
you can't molest my kids I'll let them
you know it's only going to be done by
my own Yeah by my preacher yeah yeah
yeah yeah not a guy with lipstick which
again it's not like I do think I just
don't think I just don't I'm not
convinced that the numbers are that big
where it's like all of a sudden all
these kids are transitioning because
they think it's cool I think it's so
hard to do that like people would say
that about like uh in like sports right
or like Leah Thompson they were talking
about that swimmer yeah who like was
trans then was like a much better
swimmer as a woman than than she was as
a man
the idea that you would cut your dick
off to win [__] College swimming
do you really want to you really want
that bronze medal in College swimming
that bad that you're going to chop your
nuts off it's like I don't know that's
like and then have people like you'd
swim faster without you yeah that's
might be weighing you down sure you're a
seal but it's just like I guess I'm not
convinced that like I think a lot of
this [__] is just fear-mongering for no
reason yeah and especially when you see
the statistics like I saw some poll I
don't know I don't know if like we can
find it but it was like there's like a
poll of [__] of like the percentage
people thought a bunch of things not
just trans but like a ton of stuff like
right how many people are a Muslim in
America how many people are like get
whatever and everyone overestimated
everything and that like I think I
literally think Tran like a percentage
of trans people America is like like one
percent I think we looked at the other
day it was 1.7 million about five
percent young adults say their gender is
different from their tax number see now
this article sounds so delusional to me
right yeah five percent of Youth it
could be now that could be they asked a
hundred youths in Brooklyn yeah outside
you know that that's the thing about
articles you just don't know but that
kind of percentage Yeah you see that it
could definitely make people think
what's going on and then you get yeah
you get scared why else is so scary man
I also think there's a difference
between like fully transitioning and
being like hey I do think there's a lot
of kids who are like hey maybe I'm
non-binary yeah I'm like I'm not going
to change anything medically but like
maybe I'm gonna start instead of being
called Eric my name is now sock yeah and
I'm half a guy you know what I mean like
like it is there is like there is some
change in that I think definitely I
think I have more like young friends who
are like maybe in open to experimenting
with gender in that they think you know
the way every generation has different
radical ideas to older people and I
think that's another thing I try and
think about is like you don't want to be
the old guy who's like well that's not
right that's not how I had it yeah you
know what I mean like the part of me is
like I defer to young people sometimes a
little bit or it's like and some of this
like people are gonna find themselves
and they're gonna like settle down and
it's like whatever they might those
percentages might like drop or whatever
but it's just like I think this [__] is
kind of like fluid and like always
changing but ultimately I don't think
it's dangerous like that's the thing
it's like who gives a [__] if somebody
wants to change their name or like be
perceived as something else I don't
understand why you [__] care yeah oh
I don't I don't think I feel like a lot
of people probably don't yeah yeah but I
think if it came to a point where then a
kid could go get say If I'm 14 right
yeah sure and I don't know how I'm
feeling right yeah maybe I'm gay maybe
I'm straight maybe uh women just don't
like me bro I mean there was times when
I was younger when I thought that women
didn't like me enough that I thought
maybe I'm supposed to like men dude me
too I was like I was like maybe I'll
just I was like there must be something
wrong with me yeah yeah yeah you know
yeah yeah that maybe in my head somehow
I'm messed up I'm not messed up but I am
I'm just not seeing things clearly yeah
you know and for sure no I'm with you
there so say if you're going through
that and then you decide to that's where
it's like I just don't like it when
there's possibility for the drugs to get
involved that's the part for me that's
like
man I don't know because I got on
antidepressants at a young age and I
can't get off of them yeah yeah you know
so I don't know it's it's definitely
interesting and I think look we've had
some good thoughts about it you know
some good like discussion about it and I
will say just from uh like I've hooked
up with some people who are they them
non-binary I've gotten some excellent
they then [__] damn really yeah yeah
absolutely wow brother no joke I'm the
best head I've gotten is a tie between
two they them
wow people it was awesome damn yeah it
would probably traditionally appear
though you know they they if you saw
them you'd probably oh yeah you know
what I mean but still yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so shout out to you know they
them [__] is very powerful and it's out
there the Lord's leap year
babies ugly exactly look a lot of like
Asian people I think are have a or uh uh
are against this sort of thing they're
very like gender yeah you know you
samurai or ninja yeah they're even
starting to name their kids I think like
him him was one of them
it's like nobody's confusing my son
amen
that was lame that was a little joke
you know what's interesting man is that
I wonder a lot what Nature's doing like
because that's what we don't know we
don't know what nature is doing yeah we
don't know every second that we are a
lot every like right now right now right
now that's what nature is doing yep so
we don't know also if nature is doing
something genetically where in the
future we're all gonna be
one color or one yeah you know
ambidextrous yeah wearing like just an
ambidextrous holster
our way that's true you could like
remember like uh like WWE figures where
you could like switch the heads and it
was like maybe you have a genital soon
it could it's like you [__] you just
you flip your dick it goes into your ass
and now you got a [__] or maybe you got
a [__] under your balls maybe that's
how we evolve oh imagine if you lifted
up your balls and get a vagina vagina
right under it oh like now it's time for
the show
yeah rope that's on your leg
your balls to spread apart like their
curtains yeah
um yeah but I just then why are they I
don't know why if it's a small thing and
I feel like it's a I just feel like it's
such a sensitive topic for whoever's
really going through that yeah yeah that
I don't know if it's the right thing for
a company to come along
I don't know see you know what I'm
saying I don't know what you're saying
like or what I'm I'm questioning I just
I don't know I just want to feel that
out I understand the question I think
like pause I think anything that kind of
normalizes a struggle that somebody's
going through is fine you know is like
okay like I see what you're saying where
it's like it brings attention to it and
the negative attention to me is a
problem but it's like it's on the people
who are negative about it like you know
I'm obviously very like I just don't
I think the real problems are the
legislative is the legislative stuff
that's happening against trans people
personally yeah where it's like it's
making their lives difficult it's making
some people not be able to get like
medical care it's you know well
insurance will make find any reason not
to give you anything well that's the
other thing it's like yeah that's
another problem with our country where
it's like so many of our biggest
problems come down to we don't have our
Basics covered in the richest country in
the history of the world which is so
[__] up like no one should be [__]
well it's not profitable it's not you
know yeah it comes down to a bottom line
you start to feel like a you know you
start to feel like a pawn I think that's
I think that's another thing it's such a
time where everything that the media
does feels like someone is being pawned
that I think that just the everything
these days I feel like kind of makes me
a little bit nervous yeah you know I I'm
with you too I am a little I'm like
What's the shell game here yeah yeah
yeah I'm a little pessimistic about the
course we're on in general just because
of like you know global warming [__] but
also like inequality in America is so
crazy where it's like yeah dude and I
think a lot of the anger that you see in
general like even like even for some
people trans has become like a boogeyman
and it's like they're angry because yeah
their family member has [__] cancer
insurance doesn't cover it their job has
been you know their job is gone there's
no [__] you know a train gets
derailed no one's [__] cleaning it up
now they have [__] poison in their in
their water and it's like these are all
things that could be covered with like
if we held our government accountable
and they just like we had to they had to
provide basic needs for people yeah but
everything is gone kind of to [__] and
it's like it's easy to start disagreeing
about the stuff that does not matter
when you're just so angry because you
feel like you're getting sued because we
are getting screwed but we're getting
screwed by in my opinion big
corporations by everyone who's just like
gobbling up all the money and making
sure that it's like you know wait you
know wages having place with inflation
you know minimum wage if it was like
what it was in the 70s now it should be
like you know like 40 bucks an hour or
something you know what I mean like
I think that's the root of all like our
disagreements and all our all the anger
here and I think
oh yeah when people don't feel like
they're not belonged to yeah like
they're taken care of or they used to
feel like you also well at the same time
that you're kicking down the traditions
of the country yeah you know and at the
same time that you're taking you're
taking away like or you're making it
harder I think I don't know it's a lot
there's a lot of stuff I'm not trying to
not talk think about it it's just a lot
yeah no and maybe I'll curve maybe I'll
turn the subject so we can get into
something a little happier yeah funny
ones we can go into okay let's get into
one or two funnier ones man talk about
that look man I love thinking about it
I'm with you too I mean I just I really
I think it's important to talk to think
about for sure you know because I that's
the thing I don't I don't know anybody
that is trans and a lot of my friends
don't you know and I'm even in La five
months yeah yeah yeah I have some French
oh wait we have one we had a guest Robin
Tran Robin Tran I believe so yeah and
that is a little on the nose I mean
Robin Tran is a comedian and I don't
know she didn't have the surgery at that
time okay
um
uh
and then Joe Dash
was a male comedian and he has
um I don't know Robin personally
yeah j-o-e-d-o-s-c-h
Fifi now is his name and he got a
transition okay
I believe I don't want to talk out of
pocket he's Joe's Joe's one of the most
is one of the uh
smartest and uh
just really Mo it was really a
captivating yeah um I don't know him as
much as a woman and I don't think it's I
don't know if there's a difference
between knowing someone when they are a
man or a woman wouldn't that be crazy
because I had a buddy that used to clean
the pool over at my friend's house right
yeah yeah and uh they would come every
year right and there was a big guy right
and he was awesome right and then one
year he came dude he lost a lot of
weight and I was out there just catching
some d right yeah yeah vitamin vitamin
and uh
you're out there all getting spit
roasted
catching something you go to extreme you
just feel like if you're catching some D
you're getting more than one you know
what I mean it's like if you're getting
a d it's different catching some I guess
I thought about like the way vitamin D
is like you're being bombarded with
sunlight I guess I was thinking
bombarded with dick yeah yeah you know
that's why I went right to spin roasted
you're right you're right
it's just even hypothetically I don't
want to be doing that much gay stuff but
um
but what happened then uh oh and we need
lost so much weight I didn't first of
all I didn't really know it was him I'm
like who's this guy who's just talking
who's this piece of ass yeah we have
three friends
that's just talking to me so much
um and then I was like oh my God he
seemed like a different guy yeah yeah
yeah so that's what I wonder too if you
met if it was like a book if you met
talk to someone before and after how
much change is different like because
dude that's a journey
well that's the thing I remember the
first time we went to Florida when I was
a kid and I was like this is going to be
crazy
yeah but imagine every cell in your body
in your life yeah you know what I'm
saying we're going to San Fran yeah yeah
oh yeah we're going to San Francisco
brother or we're going to like yeah
Brooklyn you know yeah yeah uh yeah I
mean I think there's probably some you
probably just feel more I would just
guess you'd feel more comfortable you'd
probably feel like more yourself you
know I can't speak I can't speak to
being trans whatever but
um
you know I'm sure you just like maybe
even more pleasant to be around because
it's like anything imagine like hiding
something and then being and also it's
like a hard thing like a lot of people
don't understand it a lot of people are
could be like probably in your fam like
coming out as gay is hard enough imagine
being like numb to you to like somebody
who would have a problem with being gay
it's like coming out as five times gay
you know what I mean like going yeah I'm
a girl yeah I'm so gay I'm a girl like
that's what a that's what like a you
know like a like I'm chasing my hotel
yeah like you're like you're like the
Ultimate Warrior of gays
like bring up when the Ultimate Warrior
came in the ring
there was nothing like that brother dude
it was electric yeah yeah when that
happened that changed the scene yeah I
bet there's a lot of gay people that I
saw are like man they're stealing our
foreign
that is huge right now Gator's been like
what are we gonna do guys yeah
absolutely being a white gay guy at this
when it's like
you're not even gay
and maybe that's what some of these guys
are doing I mean well I would I would go
costume I mean yeah dude wrestling is so
gay it's like and I wonder what does a
nature have plan because Nature's done
some wild stuff too we used to be
caveman right she used to be monkeys
right so it's like what is a lot of rape
in nature [__] up
we're much more civilized now yeah you
know but I feel like we're just a
[__] screen just we're just right
behind a screen door yeah yeah yeah
power goes out for like two weeks in a
row shit's gonna go bad dude in 40
minutes power goes out I'd be holding my
sister's hand
well again that might be cold it might
be have to again cultural having to do
with you know saying Cooter you know it
was to make sure she's okay
but it's like how you know you find it
now well you're just like dude
that's another thing or there are a lot
of power outage gays out there yeah
absolutely it doesn't even take long the
lights flicker you're like
what the hell man some guy some guy just
backed up against the light the light
switch it wasn't even an outage yeah
yeah it was a garage door opener just
tripped it
dude calm down without a cloud in the
sky
uh what's another news thing were there
a lot of like secret gay guys where you
were growing up
well when I was growing up they had
you know I've talked about this before
but they had a rest area back behind our
at a river back behind us and they had a
rest area back there and a lot of gay
men would float on float in almost a
river it was drugged people were back
there drugging nice but you do enough
drugs absolutely you do gay yeah yeah
yeah yeah and so that's when they and
they had a lot of guys are uh they had
and they had these um
these dudes with like one of those
potato launchers like those and they
would every time yeah if they had two
men that got a little too they would
shoot a couple spuds at them they just
fire a tie down
and it wasn't like trying to hit him but
it was like hey yeah you know the way
you hit a dog with a rolled up newspaper
just a little warning a shot across the
bow yeah yeah just a shot of just
something to listen hey fellas we know
you're here we see what's going on yeah
we respect it yeah but also we know
you're just drugged up right now right
right and we want to come to come drunk
yeah thinking about what you're you know
how you're gonna explain this to your
fiance yeah yeah you don't want to come
to and be like damn I didn't know they
had a Cinnabon in town
they started making Savory Cinnabons
[__] dude all right what would you have
there Bubba
trying to remember what was happening in
the news I'm trying to remember if we
had any secret gay guys in Greektown
oh well that happened and then they had
a guy who was mentally
he had a baby he had a um
he drove a bicycle right and he had a he
was mentally handicapped yeah yeah yeah
right full Downs what are we talking a
little touch ups we had a couple guys
yeah so he
it was like kind of like
uh
uh you know he was kind of like uh
he was
um
he was like hide and go special kind of
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you didn't
know yet I know yeah to get near the
fence and Stimpy close-up to really see
it yeah far away
so and then this is what happened so he
and he and he would ride around town
right his parents got him a bike or
something when he was like 30. okay for
good behavior I'm not sure I don't know
what he was like at home
but his parents so he would always be in
town yeah cruising the streets everybody
was like he's gay you know
and
the story was he had like they put a
baby seat on his bike right okay and so
there was like um like an old wives tale
or whatever that
he had a husband like a little husband
that had left him oh that sucks
so there was like there was kind of room
there were some people were like you
know get these queers out of here you
know and there was other people that
were just like you know kind of
heartbroken for him of course because
here he was that he'd had somebody that
he'd lost you know or that had left and
so people were always like so the baby
she was for the little husband yeah it's
not for the baby okay so we're talking
he's a baby-sized husband well that's
what people said yeah
Filipino guy or what are we thinking I
don't know did you guys what kind of how
many Asians did you have grown up
doesn't feel like we didn't have any
there was a rumored Asian actually uh
they had remember when Pizza Hut had
those unique rooftops bring it up buddy
sure they're yeah remember when Pizza
Hut had those unique rooftops yeah
absolutely you still see it you go to a
town and it's like a bank and that's
it's like wait that's a [__] Pizza
Hut yeah or like a mattress discounters
it's like I know that roof [__]
yeah they used to be [__] deep dish
in here oh there you go right there God
it was beautiful it really was well one
of those uh it's a travesty that they're
not they don't do the sit-down Pizza
Huts anymore they're all takeaways that
is one of the saddest things it [__]
sucks it's a track when you grow up poor
sitting down in a Pizza Hut that was
Thanksgiving I truly do those little car
the Red Cups the stained glass oh the um
the then some of the pizza pans they
even had like a uh cork or something on
it I think underneath yes yeah
absolutely it felt as the first time so
they would bring out the like cast iron
and you're like oh my God yeah who are
we yeah this is crazy I've never seen it
yes it was a Titanic
surely dude it was like that and like
our big place was like Applebee's when
it first came out oh yeah like they
first got the East Point Mall in
Baltimore and Dundalk Maryland uh my
family would go there and then uh
Chili's as well but in those days it was
Pizza Hut or Applebee's and that was
like yeah that was when we were [__]
oh that's fancy yeah that'll make it
yeah absolutely
um but one of those had burned down
right and so that rooftop that unique
roof was fresh on the ground no no and
so people uh I guess a rumor got started
that an Asian family moved in town or
whatever because it looks like a dojo
because the shape is dojo Asian Shake
like uh
[Laughter]
yeah is that it that's like the Korean
like Stone Bowl yeah yeah it had like a
it had a Asian shake
you know and so people were like yeah
they had an Asian government Slidell
Louisiana so okay armor we saved that
money we [__] saved up money to get a
taxi to go over there
to try and catch him or just to see him
yeah yeah I remember we got there and
we're like [__] do you legitimately
think you could have made money showing
like if you had like a guy from Thailand
in like a little enclosure could you
charge people from Slidell to look at
him
not now but back then
like much but yeah but maybe maybe like
a quarter just take a peek oh I think
for 50 cents people would stop by
but now a lot of people don't know
Louisiana has some of the most
Vietnamese people in the whole world
really because of the fishing yeah we
had the first Vietnamese House of
Representative House of Representative
yeah representative all right
but yeah back then they didn't happen in
Houston there's so many Viet Vietnamese
people because I don't know why but they
got good ass Fiat food dude yeah Houston
has a crazy Vietnamese population wow I
was I was just there and I was like damn
I would love to get like a like a chubby
Vietnamese wife you know what I mean
yeah that would be awesome grew up
around black people just a lot of
culture shock the viets and blacks get
along do you think I think in Houston
just because that's who's there you know
and I think there's definitely
a Boy Can Dream anyway
I'm like a like a half like a a mixed
Vietnamese black wife yeah big titties
knows how to cook pho oh it would be
awesome yeah I really would like a
little some because everyone in my
favorites
[Laughter]
there's no there's no end to it brother
that's my dream yeah I want because my
brothers both married white women and no
nothing wrong with that but I just feel
like I gotta get a little something
going what are you a white denier do you
think
I think I am in some ways not denier but
like I I just think like it would be fun
to get a little something different in
the family photos yeah you know just a
little mix it up a little bit I just
think that would be kind of nice
but that and like my dream would be like
a Greek girl like you know Yana said the
tacumbo he's Greek he grew up in Athens
but he's ethnically a Nigerian like a
Greek and that like he's an ethnic and
American right yeah yeah
is that right I think that's right
Anthony
Athenian American man yeah yeah yeah
um my dream would be like somebody who
speaks Greek but like
just doesn't look you know what I mean
just just to get a little just to get
the like like Memphis Greek get some fun
in the bloodline yeah yeah mix it up
well you know well that I think look
I've long said that we're all gonna it's
in three four five generations it's
gonna be a lot of like Ben simmonsy sure
very well even you're sneaky because you
said your dad's right my father's from
Bluefield to Nicaragua right and so
Bluefields yeah that's hilarious like a
coastal area bring it up I've never been
really have you you've never been
Nicaragua at all duh you gotta go though
I know that'd be interesting but see
even what I'm saying is like you got a
little she's got a little something in
the mix so many people do yeah
absolutely that's the thing like even
when you look back on like
like
you talk about like slavery repre it's
almost like I wish they'd just had some
of the invoices
yeah yeah so we can so we could be like
look or if somebody's all the same Fruit
of the Loom then they're you know they
get a little Larry through the loom your
butt you know yeah
Donnie Haynes yeah yeah
um
like a fake name Nicaragua
yeah dude you got to go they'll be sick
just I mean I don't know if you gotta go
to Blue Fields I don't know if it's cool
or not but you should at least go to
Nicaragua I've met some people on
airplanes and stuff and they've told me
about it [__] yeah dude so you but yeah
my father would speak Spanish a lot and
he would go to he worked as like a uh
I don't know he didn't work that much I
think
the opposite of The Stereotype yeah you
know I think there was a time when he
did I mean he was 70 when I met him my
dad was very old yeah yeah so yeah
that's another wrinkle yeah let's just
say that in any more podcasts
but it was still I mean I know what you
mean but it's still so interesting yeah
like like I don't know how in depth
you've gotten with it but that is like a
that's something to explore so much
having such an old ass dad made me so
aware I was just like is Dad okay what's
going on like it was never like in my
okay you know like oh you really felt
mortality at a time when most kids don't
even consider it oh it's scared of
everything yeah because like even
Grandpa like if when grandparents die
that's usually a kid's first entree into
oh wait this [__] might not last forever
but it's like an old ass grandparent
when is your [__] dad you're like
wait the guy's supposed to protect me as
old as [__] and my mom was very cheap
like you should get to school you should
well you should get to school your dad's
gonna die
drop it into whatever
yeah you want your dad's last memory of
you being cut in class get some good
grades dude he's on death's door yeah I
developed this cut this concept in my
head that if I
did everything perfect that my dad would
stay alive that's [__] wild dude that
crazy that's like that's like light OCD
it sounds like I didn't realize that
till like last year I did that Ayahuasca
stuff and it made me think and that came
to it that came to my I was like man
yeah when I real when I thought that I'd
never I hadn't thought it for like my
whole life yeah except me when I was
young yeah I just burst down crying yeah
dude reminds you that [__] it's so
[__] up a little kid having that
carrying that oh you should be thinking
about [__] baseball cards and Trish
Stratus is everything okay my dad will
just yeah I think it's just oh part of
it is like yeah you're just heartbroken
for the kid as in a child you know of
course I'm not trying to get into
self-pity but interesting
dude no that's wild you deserve to be
like damn that was [__] up it's
interesting man what's going on in the
world I think the scare I just get so
scared I get so
activated about how our media use just
trickily use this stuff against us
because they don't seem to have a real
care about the general well-being of
people oh yeah I mean especially once we
go to like 24-hour news and you're
selling advertising it's like when the
news was like couple times a day and
we're telling you just what happened and
we're not worried about selling ads then
yeah you could probably trust it but now
it's like everyone does have an agenda
and you do kind of have to like cut
through what the [__] being said yeah
and corporate media is just so it's just
like they're invested in keeping like
everything the same and not really
helping anyone and not telling you
what's [__] up yeah they want to keep
in the same pattern too it's just like
you've been uh your race keeps you down
or you're uh where you're from your
Christianity keeps you or just it's just
something you know it's always something
and yeah if you look at the patterns
like damn that's the same pattern yeah
it's just it's I think they're invested
in the status quo and the like you know
just
yeah I think [__] that doesn't really
affect you and they're not they don't
want to talk about I don't know [__]
that are day to day our day the [__]
these [__] up [__] that's like damn
you know our government did this like
they [__] up this many countries like
you know like all the CIA [__] all the
like uh you know just just again I I
like inequality [__] like culture War
stuff is easier yeah because it's like
because it's so divisive people feel it
so deeply but ultimately it doesn't
matter you know what I mean it's like we
all it's like going back to the same
[__] it's like yeah you're like your
dad's from Nicaragua it's like even like
we're all the same matter right we're
all the same people everyone's exactly
the same or not everyone's exactly the
same but we all have something in us
that's we can relate to everyone and we
are different in ways that are cool like
that's even going back to what I was
saying about it'd be cool to have
somebody from a different culture in my
family like I feel like I have to bring
that into my family just because it's
like I don't know I feel like I have a
better time when I'm with diff people
different from me oh yeah do you ever
get the nuggets and they accidentally
put a fry in that bed yeah dude give me
a couple of freaking fries give me a
spicy nug yeah but even with com like to
bring the conversation kind of back to
Comedy it's like I like when crowds are
different from like I like seeing people
that I have nothing like that you
wouldn't think it's just I'm like bro
like older couples have started coming
to my shows or like people different
races whatever it's like and even like
oh yeah comedy shows it's like I like
doing shows with Comics that are not
like me like I like bringing people who
have different experiences even on my
podcast it's like let me get some gay
dude you know I mean like let me get
some gay dudes let me get some like we
need some gays in here huh get some gays
in here dude damn we got some good gays
get Mateo in here he's the man oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um
yeah I think uh it's cool but it is cool
to be around people that are different
than you and just kind of like soak all
that [__] up and you know oh yeah have a
good ass time eat some different foods
suck some different color vegetables
they should have gay Foods
yeah what would be a gay food I think a
clear bro anything that easy on the old
butthole I think
anything clear broth
yeah that could be part of the Barbara
Pho yeah it's like just a clear broth
for our gay friends it's like
yeah dude I just wanna it's so
interesting to think like what is
history going to be like um but it's
interesting with cult with ethnicities
because we truly only win as a people
right if we all win right yeah that's
the only way that like Humanity if you
hope that a thousand years for whatever
it is that everybody
that's why sometimes I think it's almost
like different ethnicities and cultures
have like different parts of like the
per whatever is going to bring everybody
Voltron yeah we gotta yeah come to you I
mean I do think you're right in terms of
like it's got to be like a collective
thing yeah like people realize like I
think most people I think America's held
down a little bit by like the richest in
our country where it's like
[__] is hard you know the inequality is
crazy they have a lot of resources like
you know these [__] have
islands and it's like people don't have
[__] water and it's like or you know
people can't like don't have a living
wage or like you look at how Walmart
treats their [__] workers they're
busting their asses and it's like yeah
they're on [__] food stamps it's like
you got yeah it's like come on like that
like and so I do think there's like a
collective thing where it's like if
everybody realizes that there's a few
people [__] our [__] up you could you
know there's like a there is like a you
know that's what I think like labor
unions are good where it's like you
could just be like hey we do all the
[__] work like you should just you
know have to like there's this weird
thing where it's like even like child
labor is back in certain places like
that's how much they don't want to pay
people a living wage if they're like uh
they're rolling back like child
protection laws it's kind of [__]
wild dude wow but I didn't know that
yeah there was a couple there's a couple
of states that they just started doing
that [__] and it was [__] it was
[__] crazy but I do think that it's
it's fat yeah it's like how can people
survive on these on on
wages you know yeah no it's [__] up
it's also like some jobs are like
stair-step jobs like to advance yeah
yeah yeah but for some people maybe
they're not these days it's just it's
it's it's child labor laws are under
attack in States across the country amid
increasing child labor violations
lawmakers must act to strengthen
standards yeah they're like and they're
just even the laws that we have on on
file they're just kind of like ignoring
them and [__] it's kind of crazy I think
we're in a we're in like I think it
feels Lawless right now [__] is kind of
crumbling and it's like like we even are
like basic [__] it's like the
infrastructure in this country sucks
dick yeah the roads are bam track yeah
it's like yeah I mean don't get me
started on that [__] I'd rather FedEx
myself somewhere yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah put me in a poke some holes in
a box easy yeah which sucks too because
in this country there used to be so much
rail but that was I mean Amtrak was fun
as [__] dude that's the other thing it's
like when you go back in time you look
at history it's like car companies
destroyed rail in this country but then
they let them Lobby against it so that
they could so that it wouldn't even be
competitive you know I just wonder are
we sitting on the down or do we get to a
point where greed and that sort of thing
has happened so much that it's like
this is where you end up yeah absolutely
I think that's the logical end of like
always putting profits over everything
it's like I'm not saying you shouldn't
make a you know I think a living you
shouldn't make a profit but it's like
there is something [__] up when it's
like that's the only goal I think you
make a good living you have a product
that makes a good amount of money you
should also pay your [__] work like I
have a problem with Amazon but if Amazon
just took some of their profits and paid
their [__] workers better and made
sure they all got like health insurance
and [__] and be like that's the best
company well now the profits would be a
little Pro worse but it's like I think
you could that it should be a twin goal
of like make profits and provide yeah
for the people that like work for you
and [__] but yeah it's interesting it's
like um there's a lot it's like because
you ask somebody who's a business person
and they'll you know they'll say
um like Mike Rowe was on here and he
said well people just don't want to do
jobs they don't want to work anymore
it's so it and there can be an article
that's created to kind of make you think
anything of course that's the scariest
part it's like yeah and not know like we
don't you know we know our instincts
yeah right yeah but um I think it's
unbelievable that there's P that there
are they should put a cap on wealth I
believe I I'm with you actually fully
like when you look at like the like how
we got out of the Great Depression and
[__] and all that kind of stuff it's
like after a certain point it's like you
look it could be a crazy number 20
million dollars a year whatever it's
like after a certain point it's like
okay tax that rate high and then [__]
provide basics for people yeah you know
and it's like it doesn't have to be like
poverty like it doesn't have to be like
no one's allowed to make any money but
it's like it's I do think it's in it's
like a moral issue in America that we
have so much homelessness and so much of
it is like
[__] people that were in the Army you
know it's like it's [__] and like how
much teachers make it's like why the
[__] is a is a teacher getting paid 34
000 a year but like a consultant you
know what I mean like some [__] fake
job where they tell you to like oh slash
prices to make more profits why do they
make two hundred thousand dollars a year
whatever it's like that's the [__] where
I just feel like yeah I don't feel like
a very political person but it's like
when I start talking to me it sounds
like it sounds like I'm a [__]
communist but I'm just like no man just
like we should provide for the weakest
in a society when we have so much money
and that's that's like my belief is that
like yeah we should just provide for for
like people and I think you see it with
like you know you still want people to
work you still want that right of course
but then like it's you know I don't know
it's there's a lot of there's a lot of
like Nuance to all of it but I don't
think that
um but then also you have people that'll
go and have 20 kids yeah and they don't
have any social responsibility to the
fact that
when you do that and have no plan yeah
or anything that the drain you're
putting on society is unbelievable sure
you know just with your own real Cooter
of course once you got the Cooter
[__] humming what you got that hot
Cooter humming
so I used to think they should take your
nuts away when you're born give them
back when you graduate high school that
would be a great idea that would be
awesome I would love to be able to put
my nuts on ice for a little bit oh yeah
and then make Disney put it to music
it's doing triple axles yeah
[Laughter]
he's looking puffy these days Stavros
thanks so much man I think we've gone
through a lot do you absolutely this is
a great episode dude I mean we even got
serious about stuff so we did yeah we're
not serious guys really though I know
but it is fun to think about this [__]
yeah it's okay to get serious sometimes
I think so yeah I think there's just a
lot going on too yeah it's a it's a
strange time and then how much of it is
just a trap whether it's just like hey
look at this while something else is
going on you know yeah we're fighting
we're over here you know people are
arguing about um
you know uh uh uh young you know a trans
beer can yeah that would that's exactly
and meanwhile there's like half or you
know they're shipping away a ton of our
money or they're doing this or you know
fully dude
weird I think it's all I think all that
culture War stuff all the especially gay
and trans issues it's textbook
let's get you to not pay attention to
the economic issues that are actually
ruining your life and making you this
angry
um so I don't know I mean I think that's
a big like I'm I was a big Bernie guy
when it came to the election last time
and I thought like it may I think him
versus Trump actually would have made a
lot of sense because it's like
there's anger like that's there was a
populism behind Trump that the Democrats
would have been smart to like do the to
pick their populist candidate and the
one saying like no big business is
[__] us like we have to [__] like
we have to fight back against this or
they'll take advantage of us and I do
think that I mean it just comes down to
that man when people are like angry it's
easy to keep them distracted with [__]
that ultimately the guy wants to wear a
dress let the [__] guy wearing dress
but like give me Health Care yeah like
make sure make it so that if my grandma
he gets like if my mom gets a treatable
skin cancer she gets to live and not go
bankrupt and that and it's like when
people are so mad about the fact you
know they're so round up about all the
negative [__] in their lives that it's
easy to channel that into anger against
you know groups that are kind of [__]
marginalized and whose lives are hard
enough already but everybody's life is
kind of funny but that's another thing
too it's like this constant like yeah
and the quality of life is going down so
bad the health care can't just be you
know they can't focus Focus only on the
fat like I don't know it's just
interesting it's like
because kids can go to a therapist now
and say something and the therapist can
put them on a drug do the parents have
the ability to stop them but that's
crazy if your kids like 12 and he's like
I feel like a man woman yeah yeah I
don't know you may have a closer
connection to it yeah and look none of
these none of these issues are like kind
of dry that's the other thing it's like
these are Case by case yeah again not
that many [__] statistically not that
money and that's the thing even us
talking about it this much [__] I know
we [__] up but hey what are you gonna
do the important thing is people watch
the crowd work special yeah you know
that's important yeah no matter how
you're yeah no matter what's going on in
your uh genetics yeah or a diaper come
any kind of genitals come to this fat
Rascal tour we won't check to see what
you got you know unless you want me to I
might think it's pretty crazy start
checking people yeah what you got in
there
empty out your purse sir
oh [__] dude all right cool man we'll go
check it out I think it's might be the
longest episode I've ever done hell yeah
dude I got another I'm down this is
awesome it was funny [__] it's hot in
here though it is hot it's been I had a
hot flight here
like one of those like you know when
you're like not you're so hot your
body's just like having like a fever nap
almost I was like I was like do I have a
fever am I about to like give [__]
Theo covid but I was just hot in the
airplane it turns out don't worry uh but
yeah but I'm feeling I'm I can't wait to
crack that door and just feel like
that's that's our reward for this
podcast I just feel in that breeze
that's it we're like two of those kids
that have to mine for the iPhones or
whatever
and their lunch break is just cool air
yeah
who wants lunch don't fill up yeah
don't get your lungs too comfortable you
got another 12 hours in the mines
[Laughter]
god dude and it's so sick or even
laughing
I know it sucks but man but we are not
really laughing about it God bless you
guys bro thank you starboards for being
here man thank you brother yeah I'm so
excited to see the new special that
comes out tomorrow tomorrow yep so crowd
work special just for fun the real the
real big dick specials coming in the
fall I'm recording it in May uh at the
Paramount in Austin I can't believe yeah
that'll be really fun and it'll come out
sometime in the fall but just a little
something to tie the people over you
know you're gonna go to Rogan's new club
I went dude I was checking out the
Paramount I was scouting it on opening
night and so I didn't I wasn't on the
shows but I went to check it out dude
it's [__] awesome really dude it's so
like you walked in there and it was like
whoa there was like of energy there I
can't wait to go back and do spots there
for sure yeah um I'm excited I'm gonna
pick up some extra spots here when I'm
down in Austin oh yeah dude congrats on
the uh oh [__] congrats on the specials
man thank you brother all right
[Music]
rolling like these leaves I must be
Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of my life
[Music]
gonna take